Lav is included in the defendant's initial disclosures as
an also go yeah there's no reason for him to protected I'm glad
that they protected this person's identity they could really
be in a lot of trouble this person's apparently been threatened
whoever this person is could have been in a lot of trouble if
their identity was exposed
now good times why is he so racist this. I don't know why he
keeps pointing out that this judge is from Puerto Rico. Puerto
Ricans are Americans, right? He's like, "Oh, that's what is He's
He's literally like one of the androids from um from Westworld."
Okay. He sees a screenshot of somebody asking for explicit consent.
He's like, "Doesn't look like anything to me. It's a conspiracy."
What? I have no idea what's going on here. Too much. Okay. If
you're a DGer, you have to look at this silence and be like,
"Wait, I thought we were winning, buddy. Buddy, we were winning.
I thought we were Aren't we doing good? I thought we were doing
so good. Wait, why are you Why are you totally silent
well, let's check it out. Let's see what he had to say. 10 pager.
I do want to get to the part cuz I know cuz people already linked
me that he reacted to my stream and he got so hilariously ass
mad at my stream that I had to I was like, dude, it's so funny
how angry he's just like seething on the stream and I'm like
dying laughing. I'm dying laughing while I can hear myself dying
laughing and watching him see about it. Like I can hear my laugh
going. I'm actually laughing in the room while he's just seething
on the stream. It was very goofy. Okay, I'll see if I can recreate
their balls to get this out tonight. Okay.
Defendant Steven Bunnel the second is a prominent online content
creator and live stream with over 840,000 followers. Since the
initiation of his lawsuit, defendant has repeatedly discussed
and published details of the litigation on his public platforms.
You know, he wanted to pause and go, "Hold
842,000. Stop taking inches off my
Miss, what's the
Joanne? Joanne. Oh, the I I got lost the last name. God damn
it. God damn it. Sorry. I'm I'm normally getting by now, but
I had to come back and stream for you guys. Okay.
Why can't I remember her name? Female council for Pixie. God,
never mind. And home addresses of council and even someone's
excuse me, all of this information is public. It's literally
at the end of all of your
the names and home address. What home? Yeah, it's just normally
like hold on
names. Okay, the name of the leader of Israel is public, but
if it's, you know, if it's Mr. Nasra,
um, RIP, okay, if it's if it's Nasra talking about Benjamin Netanyahu,
talking about how evil Israel is is, is a little different than
just like that name being public. Okay, that's like a that's
a goofy little analogy, but I'm just saying that obviously even
if herit was public. Okay, even if herit was public, I'll move
my over. Yeah, even if your was public, obviously Destiny is
like railing on these people and saying that they're borderline
like breaking the law to go after him maliciously, right? Also,
this is not quite working
correctly. That back just a little bit like that. Okay, you're
ah I've still got little holes. I've got little holes. Whatever.
Oh, that's too much. I don't like it. Hold on. Got to turn that
back down. Even if we get a little bit of the rim going. Yeah,
that's better. That's better. better. Wait, what are you covering
right? What are you covering right now? Wait, are can you not
see the screen? I'm covering Destiny's reaction to those documents
Pixie just
filed. Yeah, exactly. Dopey Wednesday. It's like he's literally
doing it while talking about how these people are trying to him
in front of people who are like loyal to him completely. Which
by the way, I'm just very embarrassed for a lot of the names
I see in this chat. Uh I mean chiefly right now, Marquette Kurtka,
that's pretty embarrassing. Um but like these people are so We'll
just get into like some of the arguments he makes. you. I genuinely
feel
like like sad for these people. Like
sad. Very very sad. Whatever the end of your Am I Oh, hey Ry.
Wow. Thanks for the five gifted. Very cool. Very cool. Very cool.
Very cool. Is it illegal? Is it illegal for me to show the to
show the public filings? Hello.
Uh no, it's not illegal. They're actually saying they're actually
explicitly saying although this conduct is not illegal, we would
like a gag order saying that he should not be able to do this
because we feel like he's threatening the council here and other
people. Right.
That's actually the whole point of the motion, Destiny. I don't
know if you're like totally behind, but that is actually what
the point of the motion is right now is to say, "Hey, this person's
kind of unhinged, and we want you to to use your power to make
this illegal for him to do." Mrs. Judge, Ms. or Mr. Yeah. Miz
judge Jacqueline Picara.
I don't I
what what does he expect him to do?
Uh magistrate. I don't believe this protective was this protective
order going in front of the magistrate judge or is this going
in front of I thought I saw Jaclyn Baker's name on the on the
proposed order. I think this is not as a part of the preliminary
injunction. I think this is in the primary case.
Is 10 pages the limit or do they need to ask for extra? No, 10
pages is your ordinary limit, I think.
Jesus. Anyway, we could I doxed them.
Okay. And even he knows the definition of doxing, too, which
is Yeah. like collecting this information in a place and then
using it for the purpose of harassment. Like, okay,
I don't necessarily think it's wrong to go over these without
uh without redacting, but if you're going to go over and say
that these people are like evil, possibly, especially if you've
got a big enough audience, there's probably, you know, as you
get larger and your audience is capable of more and more, I'd
get a little more worried about it, right, with as you scale
as a content creator. Some of the discussions, he's also made
derogatory and intimidating statements about the plane. He's
super highlighting. Well, it's just funny that this whole time
he's going to go through and highlight the precise behavior that
they're pointing out and saying this is what we think is bad.
This is this is why we think we need a projective order and his
entire stream is just doing every behavior every type of behavior
that they suggest is like the reason it's I don't know man it's
crazy I can make derogatory statements I want. This is a free
country baby intimidating statements. What I what and statements
about the plaintiff her council plaintiff's witnesses and her
perspect pro perspective
witnesses how bro you've already you filed the lawsuit like what
four months ago and you're and you're looking at pers so what
I can't say anything bad about everybody on planet
earth okay the funny thing here is I have to keep going I shouldn't
pause too much but like the very funny thing here is is obvious
viously um there's somebody very specific that he's like threatened
is me. Okay. And he's going to make the simultaneous argument.
He's made this argument multiple times that I have nothing to
do with the case. He has he doesn't think I have anything to
do with the case and that threatening me has nothing to do with
the case. But also say that he has tried to subpoena documents
related to me. So I don't know I don't know which one is the
I don't understand. Does nobody in DGG chat ever point this out
to him that you're arguing both things at the same time? You're
like, I am subpoenaing this person. This person is doing a conspiracy
against me. Also, I can threaten them and they have no connection
to the case. Can both of those things be true? How does he make
both of these arguments at the same time? Because everybody on
the planet could be a prospective witness. What does that even
mean? Okay. Damn. That's based. Okay. Based base legal tactics.
Okay.
Indeed, several witnesses, including those that provided declarations
in support of plaintiff's motion for learning injunction, have
expressed fear of being publicly targeted or doxed. This is not
a real thing for the Isn't he just saying you're not related
to the suit Pixie filed? Yeah, but he knows that's not true.
At bare minimum, at bare minimum,
uh, I am the person who told him about the leaks in the first
place and has like the original time stamp on that and the original
logs on that and can tell that story. And he knows that. He knows
that that is materially relevant to this case, right? You don't
even have to do a lot of thinking to know that that's materially
relevant to the case. What do we talk? What do you publicly targeted
by defendant and or his followers and have indicated they're
unwilling to participate in discovery or testify unless their
identities remain confidential? Oh my god.
What? I'm sorry, but like this is we're in the big boy world
now and we're if you want to be a big boy and you want to come
and do court stuff, that's fine. But we're going to move past
the this is my Twitter account and this is my Reddit and now
we're using our real life identities because we're doing Oh,
look. Now he understands. Oh, look. Now, when it's the big boy
world and he wants everybody's name on here, he understands that
a real life name and a pseudonym aren't the same thing. But for
some reason, he believes people making posts under the pseudonym
count as legally like doxing themselves somehow and he should
be able to use their legal names now. I don't I again just all
of the people in DGG chat very embarrassing lack of any IQ or
you know personal
inside internal monologue/ Chad can't talk about a dinner bell
anymore. A
wait can they not I feel like this is like actually just indicative
of a dinner bell but I don't don't worry Ry none of that was
based on reality. I didn't even respond to it. They're just goofy
people. They just try to say they just try to say things that
get under your skin. Don't worry about it, buddy. Doing a real
life court case. All right. You have to decide if you want to
do big boy things or if you want to on Twitter or Substacks.
You can't have it both ways. You have to put your big boy pants
on and you got to go to court and you have to say this is my
name. This is what I'm testifying to. That's what we do here.
Like Jesus
Christ. See plaintiff's declaration attached here too as exhibit
A. For this reason, the witness declarations were filed under
seal based.
Okay. Plaintiff is requesting that the court enter the narrowly
tailored proposed protective order attached to his exhibit B
to protect the integrity of these proceedings to prevent a chilling
effect on evidence gathering and testimony. Why don't you already
this? We're 4 months into the case. How do you not already have
Um, yeah, I think I I do think that that could be there,
but unfortunately he's continued to talk and say these things
long after the case was filed.
Uh, hello Ken the jelly man. He came back. I did come back tonight
actually. And I Isn't it up that I have to lie to you guys so
meticulously that when I said I was coming back and I promised
I didn't come back and tonight when I said I'm almost certainly
not coming back and then I come back. Isn't that up? Isn't that
up? All of this by now. What do you like? You haven't It's not
like you're serving discovery requests to us and those people
are denying things. Like what the This order would apply equally
to all trial participants and serve to protect to prevent further
public doxing, harassment, intimidation, and misinformation without
defense continuous extrajudicial
comments. I'm reading the the I'm reading your
Oh, these would be um you accusing them of perjuring themselves,
them of taking witnesses and making them lie. This would be uh
the conspiracy theories you're like creating about me or Pixie
or whoever, right? He's not you're not just reading the documents.
You're not just reading the documents. You're adding a lot of
editorialization and you're straight up defaming people. Uh,
he's going to do it again because he's once again emotionally
dregulated and asmad and he'll start making up like insane skitso
theories again. But that's okay. Well, that's okay for me. It's
funny for me. Uh, I don't know about him. He's He's kind of losing
it.
What on his Sorry, I should be clear. I don't know if he's actually
losing it. I don't know if he's losing it or if he's like giddy
at how like bad faith and he can be while his entire audience
like backs him up. He's just like, "Dude, I'm I'm like actually
Trump. I can actually shoot somebody on Fifth Avenue." Like,
oh my god, I can just say whatever the these will believe me.
Oh my god. Streaming platforms over,000 like of materially prejudicing
this
proceeding. Relevant facts. Defendant has publicly threatened
physical harm to individuals that have spoken out against him
and in support of plaintiff plaintiff for just killing equipment.
I kill him if I could. I'd show up there and do it. I do want
somebody to kill. Oh, we got the bull and
underline. Yeah, cuz you're directing other people, which like
but the entire argument in here is like he he's like directing
his audience to harass people and he's directing his audience
to like harm people and he's like immediately he like highlights
this and goes, "Oh, I guess this is what's happening.
We got the bold and underline. These two people, none of these
people are involved with this case. Why? I don't understand why
they keep they mentioned like 15 different court docks. Sorry,
that was me. That was me.
Jesus. Um, again, I if I'm not involved with the case. Okay,
so there's Wait, now I'm not involved with the case. Okay, keep
in mind he talks in this stream and in multiple other streams
about actually having subpoenaed me.
So I how is he subpoenenaing me if I have nothing to do with
the case? Wasn't that the whole reason that all of the other
testimony from those other people had nothing to do like that
shouldn't be entered because it had nothing to do with the case.
So he'll argue that I have nothing to do with the case. But apparently
he'll subpoena records about me. I don't know what these are,
by the way. I have no idea. I've not heard about this. I got
no idea. Maybe I just haven't checked my
mail. Maybe I'm getting these individuals are potential witnesses.
Bro, what? It's like Agent
What? How? The funniest part about this is the next line. How
do you not know if they're a witness yet? What in this action
due to their knowledge of the facts and related interactions
with the defendant? Indeed, Lav is included in the defendant's
initial disclosures as
an I'm sorry, that's the last time I do that just in case anybody's
trying to go to sleep. But he literally listed Lav as somebody
who might have material information to the case. Individual likely
to have discoverable information.
Hold. How does he explain that? Serve her with a subpoena.
He's so
stupid. It's literally his team has said this person may have
information related to the case and that's a person he's threatening
and says he wants to kill. He wants somebody to kill her. Why
would you don't give don't even make it. Also, by the way, they
publicly filed this initially, which is funny enough. But why
are you then you don't even you don't have to Oh, wait. Sorry.
It's Pixie team. It's Pixie team. Sir, that other person was
No, no, hold on. Defend it. No, defend it. Is it says it's Destiny's
team. Maybe it is plaintiffs. Maybe it's Pixie's team, but it
looks like it's Destiny's team. Hold on. That right there. That
says Destiny's team. So, I That was how I read it. He's now acting
like it was Pixie's team, but I thought it was Destiny. H
whatever. There's no way that's true, right? That lab's in the
Maybe this is a mistype and it's in the plaintiff's
disclosures. The defendant has tried to do. This is so cringe.
Doxing is not a thing in in big boy world. People use their real
life. Wait, no, it is it is a thing. Hold on. It is a thing if
you're trying to direct harassment with it,
right? It is. You can you can't sue somebody. There's no law
against doxing, but there are laws against like publishing somebody's
information with orders to like go hurt them. Absolutely. There
are names and they're real life sometimes their home addresses,
which mine has been exposed multiple times. In this court case,
if you want to do real life big boy things, then you have to
do real life big boy things. You don't get Wait, but hold on
now. Hold on. Now he's arguing. Is he now arguing that we are
related? Cuz I didn't. He was just arguing I'm not related. Where's
the real life big boy things that I'm doing from this point in
the I don't understand. Do you see how he just alternates between
whether or not I'm related or I'm unrelated? He can't seem to
decide. It's just whatever serves his argument best in the moment.
Get to use a a Discord username and my address is the Discord
user. Yeah, show up or off. What do you mean? The defendant has
tried to dox both queen and Jess. These people aren't parties
to any of this case. They're not parties to the case. Then why
did you just go on that rant about doxing and it's big boy world?
Also, why are you trying to subpoena people not party to the
case? See, also Google Drive and
Shamu Twitter. Those are just intent. Thank you for the Twitter
links. I can't wait for the judge to be clicking these in court.
What is this Google Drive link? Hold
on. He's very used to Oh, don't want to click any of my Google
Drive links on stream. Call you requested does not
Uhoh. Okay.
There's a space in the URL. I could probably go find out what
it is, but I'm good right now. The term dox or doxing means to
publicly identify or publish private information about someone
as a form of harassment or revenge. Does it count provided service
to me at my home address and my address is published or
Okay. What was that
response? What was the response?
Wait, didn't he just get raped by pulling up that tweet? It contradicts
what he just said. Well, that they're not part of the case. Sorry.
Wait, hold on. BB Poison, what do you mean here? I'll go back.
What do you mean when he pulls up the tweet? Who judge will be
clicking these in court?
I actually don't know what you mean, BB, but
doxing when they provided service to me. My home address and
my address is published or
provided services to me and my home address and my home address
is
Okay. Defendant regularly streams on YouTube channel. The details
of this case included confidential details from meet and confidential.
What are you talking about? We haven't decided nothing that has
been if anything has been sealed or redacted. I haven't discussed.
I believe meet and confers are supposed to actually based on
the rules for civil procedure. I believe meet and confers like
the the the conference information that is supposed to be remaining
like not public. Uh definitely settlement negotiations are supposed
to not be public. Uh like pre-trial settlement negotiations those
should not be public. Those
things after plaintiff replied to the opposition for to motion
for preliminary junction was filed. He streamed about the filings,
showing them on his screen, reading excerpts aloud, and writing
vitriolic and defamatory commentary for over an hour.
Sometime these are not just you're these are court
sometime. These are not Was he drunk for this stream? Gross.
Saying you're not involved in the case. And I think the clip
in the tweet was trying to involve you in the case saying I was
amplifying from farm. These are not confidential. You're these
are court filings. These are public filings. I'm not Am I not
allowed to read the public
filing? Also, I'm allowed to say vitriolic. Well, defamatory
is a opinion. It's my court case. I'm I'm allowed to say whatever
the it's I have a first amendment right.
Um, so the first amendment right is going to be weighed against
prejudicing the case, whether you're actually actively preventing
witnesses from coming forward. Unfortunately for Destiny, he
terrifies a lot of people. Terrifies his ex-wife will never do
anything, right? And I I I don't even blame her for that. She's
like like he is a terrifying person. Like he will go after anybody
and anybody with a career on the internet wants nothing to do
with like making statements against him. Yeah. So, obviously,
if witnesses are too scared to come forward, that is prejudicing
the the
trial. Does it matter if he does it or Darius does? Well, I that's
kind of how he's trying to get around it. I feel like they should
probably I'm almost positive they should try to um subpoena like
his communications with Darius just because I have Darius statements
on like, oh, is this what we were talking about? And then the
the messages to Wes all very concerning. Oh, and Darius like
trying to get Abby to message Destiny about getting paid to not
test. That's weird. Or not sue him. Very bizarre
stuff. This video has been viewed 120,000 times to date. In it,
defendant accuses plaintiff of extorting and blackmailing him,
of insane lies, of a total lie. Okay. Is any of this illegal?
Okay. All right. In the same video, defendant accuses plaintiff's
witness, Abby Mc. Thank you for redacting her identity. Good
job. Of lying and perjury. He refers to the undersigned council
as disgusting. True. Oh, they're personally offended. Get mad.
Joanne, if you're reading this, you are disgusting. You are a
disgusting, horrible person. You are. I hope you know that. And
I feel that way personally about you. I'll make a declaration
to the court if I need to as
well. Joanne Schlump Peters, that is the the
uh the council for Pixie, the primary council for Pixie, I believe.
No, no, no, no. Joan Schlump Peters Pixie's primary council.
He refers to the undersign council as disgusting and repeatedly
accuses the undersign council of grabbing random people to perjure
themselves. That's a defamatory statement. 100% that's a defamatory
statement. That is a thousand% a defamatory statement. One that
could be extremely damaging to her. Defendant accused Oh, he's
not going to respond to that one though. Council of bad faith
arguments, explicit lying, and abuse of the court system.
Yes, you did this. You did all four of those things. True. Respond.
True and true. So, you're continuing. Wait, wait, wait. What
about the perjuring thing? Do you notice how he actually skips
the thing that he's going to have to actually be on the on the
hook for for proving that? He just skip right by that. He doesn't
want to keep pressing that one because now they've informed him
that, hey, we think that's defamatory, right? But he's going
to he's just going to skip right by it.
He spends a full 30 minutes telling his followers that plaintiff
council has no understanding of the federal rules
of they're so assigned. Why are they why are they putting this
in in any of these filings? It has nothing to do with this
case. Wait, what? How? At what point is it Destiny is gonna like
it's gonna be that they go to Google, they subpoena Google and
they actually get back that he sent the Pixie video to like 12
different people and they have their IPs and they can go and
subpoena those people and find out yeah they did find the video
and stuff and he's literally going to see that evidence come
down and he's going to go what does that have to do with this
case? That doesn't have anything to do with this case. It's like
at what at what point the only context you know this person in
that you are currently
is in this case. At what point do we reach the point of absurdity
where you say it has nothing to do with this case?
They're actually She's actually mad. She's actually mad. Yes.
She's like ra Wait, does he actually use soundboards a lot now?
Did he Did he have to copy my soundboard, too? That's That's
embarrassing, bro. Posting on the filings. They have 10 pages.
they have 10 pages to file for their client and she's and Pixie's
like can we include this like no and then he said that I was
a he called me a dumb and he said I didn't even know the federal
rules of
procedure defended accus I just want to point out that it is
a debate strategy to only focus on like the weakest point the
other person makes and to just skip over any intelligent or strong
point they make right like he does skip over the perger themselves
thing because
In previous videos, he's also pulled back from that because obviously
somebody informed him saying that is bad. That's an actual defamatory
statement. You have no proof of that. Please don't say that again.
So he skips right over that one, right? And focuses on the other
ones. It's very funny. 30 minutes telling his plaintiff council
has no understanding of the federal superure because they allegedly
did not adhere to proper procedures by filing redacted declarations
of the witnesses along with the motion to file under seal. The
unredacted versions defendant of course is wrong since the court
granted plaintiff's motion to file under seal. So this would
be a bad faith argument. It would be explicitly lying and it
would be abuse of the court system. I like how they did all three
right here. My issue is not you filing things under seal. And
you know this because of our own filings. The issue is you thinking
that you can file things under seal while keeping those private
from us. You're not allowed to do that. Kind of like how you
I don't even know if that was his whole argument the previous
time. I'm pretty sure that he said they like they actually failed
to do things and the judge will throw them out or something.
Filed you. you. But he made sure to back off that I ran this
all by
Oh, I can't wait to see how he responds to that. Actually, yes,
if you remember from earlier when we were reading this, uh, they
actually explicitly quote Destiny when he says, "I run all everything
I say by my
council." I was like, "Dude, Andy's not going to be happy about
that one." Andy's going to be like, "No, no, no, no, no, no.
Don't put your on me, bro." That showed us a motion, asked us
to agree to it, and then you filed a different one with the court.
That's an example of explicitly lying and abuse of the court
system.
Actually, I think that's probably more just an example of bad
faith. I don't know if it's I don't think it's explicitly lying
or an abuse of the court system. It's being dishonest and it's
bad faith for sure. You're saying here's the thing we're going
to do and you file something else. That's definitely bad faith.
He actually missed the one it actually was. Okay. Jesus. That's
fine.
Defendant of course is wrong. uh this type of misinformation
about the litigation on his platform is rampant and based on
the thousands of comments on the YouTube video is accepted as
gospel by his followers.
Disturbingly all of this extrajudicial commentary is approved
by defendants council. Oh, they love throwing this one. I pass
everything that I Yeah. Well, you said it. Wait, does he Dude,
people pointing this out, Alex Jones, right, or Carl Jobs, these
people who like kept whining about their cases and actually sunk
themselves in court. It's so
funny. I don't know if that'll happen here. I really don't know
what the outcome of this case will be, but it's so funny that
Destiny's managed to create multiple additional motions that
he has to respond to because he can't shut the cup up. I Dude,
Andrew Breler is a genius. Andrew Breler has like the perfect
money-making strategy. He's like, "No, no, no. I'll totally help
you defame all of these people. I'll totally help you defame
all of these people." Yeah. Yeah. we'll like we'll do this whole
thing and secretly he's like yeah they're going to really complain
about this we're going to get like 80 different motions okay
I get to run counters to all of them I get to write all of those
counter arguments all of those counter motions all of those motions
in opposition rather okay I'm going to get so many buildable
hours he's just running a racket on like destiny I publish by
my lawyers first when I made this comment when I say publish
by the way talking about the um I think that initial me or whatever
that I did is that what he meant
uh Not that it's not like I script out all my live streams and
YouTube. I don't know what he's saying. That's what he said.
That's absolut Oh my god. Somebody get me the clip. He was like,
"You think I just go live without talking to my lawyers." He
had the whole thing where he's like, "I write up I in the morning
I get up and I write notes to my lawyers about what they should
say back and then they tell me like what I can say and then I
go live." Wasn't that like the whole thing or am I hallucinating
that? I'm almost positive that he talked about how he writes
up the like summary of information for his lawyers. He sends
it to them and then he talks about what he he they tell him what
he can talk about. I'm almost positive this happened. They know
that. They're just But okay, good
one. That's not
dude. Oh, we'll see. I I might have time with like Riyle after
this. Maybe I'll go and try to find some of these things cuz
holy sh Jesus. The defendant has also told his followers.
Destiny, you said that about the minifesto. Look at this.
Dustin, you only said it about the mini festo. Dustin, you already
explained this in that
video. H on Kiwi Farm. Are we just linking? What the Bro, I told
you they were getting their arguments from Kiwi Farm. Are they
just straight linking to the farms
Hello. The defendant has told his followers on Kiwi his followers
on Kiwi Farm. I Yeah, realistically I This is clearly mistyped,
right? What can you do? What can you do? What can you do? Not
the first up from Pixie's legal team on this filing. Unfortunately,
the Kiwi Farms are my followers. The Witness ABMC is crazy and
insane unhinged. He also informed his message to the court. We
were not making serious accusations of Andy running a racket.
We were just being facitious. Thank you. Um, yeah, I was being
facitious, but I'll just point out that as Destiny points out,
I'm not like one of the parties in the case right now. Um, I'm
actually not technically officially involved in the case in in
like any way. I I said I would as I came on uh the stream and
said I told them I'd make a statement if they could protect my
legal identity cuz I don't want my legal identity getting exposed
with this guy telling his followers that they should be trying
to kill me. I just feel like that'd be risky for me. Okay, that's
what I said.
Um yeah, so but I would if they wanted me to I would be officially
involved if they need that. That helps the case community of
the name of Abby MC's prior boyfriend because it's public knowledge.
We've all They stream. They stream together. We've all seen it.
What
Again, if it's public knowledge, then I I I'm sorry. You have
to You're an illegal case. You're the person confirming this
to other people. That's you, buddy. When it gets filed under
sealed, that's
you. Oh my god, bro. I like how Tiny thinks the judge cares where
the arguments came from. Sorry, Miss Pixie. That argument came
from Kiwi Farms. Jury strike that from the record. Yes. Like,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Are you telling me
that they posted evidence of your wrongdoing on a website called
Kiwi Farms? Well, we can't consider that evidence at all. That's
like that's that that's disgusting, sir. Mr. Bennell, do are
you aware that you've been wronged horribly? That you are actually
the biggest victim here? We should let you counters sue her.
Actually, Kiwi Farms
disgusting,
POV, you're actually winning. POV, you're totally actually winning
right now. I promise. I promise, guys. Guys, POV, you're totally
actually winning at this exact moment in
time. The defendant has also publicly doxed and attacked Lauren
Hayden.
When did I dox her? I don't I can't dox her. I don't even know
where she lives. Where the can I
I believe using the full name. Is Lauren writing all of this?
There's no way, right? There's no way that this the other lawyer
from Puerto Rico would would just hand over the docks to her,
I just want to like is it this has to be disturbing because we
all like a lot of us came from DG. This has to be disturbing
that he's actually like descending. He's actually descending
into like some QAnon level thinking, right?
Like yeah, I don't know if he if he got like high and booted
the stream up. I don't know. It's it's
crazy. Also, what were his just real quick when he when he does
talk about like the the lawyer from Puerto Rico? He keeps Puerto
R this lawyer from Puerto Rico. This lawyer from Puerto Rico
is uh is Tony Hinchcliffe writing his material now or how did
he react when Tony Hinchcliffe made the the island of garbage
comments? Okay. Why does he keep all of this or why does he keep
this uh this island? Why didn't Team Pixie redact Lauren's name?
I don't know. Well, I think at some point I think at some point
Lauren de Laguna started using Lauren Hayden publicly. I think
that could be part of it. I don't even know what they mean by
do I don't know what that is referring to
necessarily or that like Lauren is working for their officer
right there. That would be such a they would be conflicted out.
There's no way. He says Tony Hinchcliffe is funny. Oh, that's
up. That's reallyed up. Oh, given what happens later, he said
Tony Hinchcliffe was funny.
You'll understand why that's so upsetting to me a little bit
later. But how have I Lauren?
They defined it differently in the
Um Lauren Hayden or a friend doxing is collecting somebody's
personal information and then making it public for the purpose
of harassing them. Right. collecting personal information about
them and then directing harassment via their way via that like
publishing it for the purpose of harassment potential witness
of plaintiffs. Lauren is listed as an individual likely to have
discoverable information on defendants initial disclosures. If
she's your friend, then you don't need anything from me. She's
going to have she's going to have all of the information herself.
Why? Why do you even I think actually initial disclosure is disclos
whatosing to me who might have information but
like I yeah it's literally hey this person might have
information I found the pass by my defense first comments so
it's got 20 seconds of rampant time. Okay give me a second. Uh
just with this I don't dude
what it's Yeah. It's literally letting you know that we're we
might ask this person for information and you might have they
might have information so you should know about them too. It's
literally like a good faith effort to say these are people we
might actually use information from. So if you wanted to ask
them things here they are. Anyway, hold on. Apparently this is
where he talks with the the lawyers. Uh was it Professor Sunday
or I'm sorry not Professor Sunday. President Sunday's
Oh, wait a second.
Oh, wait. Hold on.
What is there a link to like the thing that I published?
Wait, I just realized something. I despite the fact that everybody
claims otherwise because people think I'm legitimately I guess
people really do think or some people I think. I don't This is
3 weeks ago. So, I don't know why this would necessarily have
to do with the manifesto. Haters or what think I'm actually insanely
arrogant. Um, I do pass by. I pass everything I publish by my
lawyers first. Some people like, I bet he's I bet he's stupid
enough to think that he's smarter than his lawyers and does like,
no, I'm not. I'm not. Why would I even risk that? A pretty good
assessment of how smart I am. I would never risk anything that
stupid. Um, but I just realize I wonder sometimes am I referencing
things that I put in a first draft of a statement and not the
actual thing that got published. Now, um,
this one, we'll see.
Where is the um I made a public I made like a when I did like
my minifigesto. Did I ever link that? I was gonna say right here
if he's talking about first draft he's talking about the
Okay. So the main things that make me
wait, hold on. Is he talking about the notes he sends to his
lawyers? Because I don't know if this is the one necessarily,
but hold on. So like for instance, when that she knew that I
was in contact with, she's saying things like um this I believe
these like pretty clearly mounts on, right? Um, I'm going to
decide reaction what to do with him or myself and him based on
how the converation goes with the video. Unless you want to talk
basically my plan of course something this conspiracy and like
I said before that Twitter archive replies the tweets. Yes, that's
very weird. Yeah, I remember covering this one. This is not quite
it but that is one of the statements but that one would apply
more to his minifesto. There's another one where he talks about
writing notes to his lawyers. Right. It's the quote. Yeah, it's
the quote but I'm saying that he has talked about how yeah I
don't just go live and talk about this without my lawyer say
so. Like I do pass things by my lawyers. And he talked about
writing his notes, but it's fine. We can
continue. She literally put her name on GoFundMe. Like what?
What the
She had her name on the give and go. I think her name is still
there, isn't it? Giveo. Am I about to dox her again?
Her and her middle name. Did I just dox her? I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. What?
I don't know what they mean by docs here, but he absolutely directs
harassment at at Lauren and defames Lauren, right? Multiple times
claiming that there's like some conspiracy here.
Like, dude, how does he argue? How could he ever go do one of
these like Trump conspiracy arguments again? Maybe I'm like totally
I understand that it's a bigger deal to talk about the election,
but the entire idea is you have like a massive following of people
who could do something in the real world. Um, when you when you
make these arguments, when you say something that is blatantly
false, that could hurt people, you're doing something wrong,
right? When you are lying about Lauren de Laguna repeatedly,
that could have effects, especially if she's trying to do something
in social media. You're going to say that she's lying. Or I mean,
just she had, I think, issues with the getting through the bar
or something in Florida, right? Like these these things could
have effects if you use their names and if you publish these
things online, they could have effects. He did also suggest filing
an ethics complaint against her. Yeah, he's like said Lauren
should be
disbarred. Like these things do have effects, especially when
you have a large enough following and and you can put weight
into the world. Like what is the argument against Hassan or bad
empanada or any of these people? How do you how do you stand
at all against bad empanada and the CPS comments or like him
talking about Ethan as a parent? What was illegal there? What
comment was
Where in the world does he get any idea that he can stand up
against bad empanad and be like, I'm a better person than
you. I It's baffling.
Uh, by the way, the point of that is that they're both bad people,
okay? Not that they're both good people, that they're both bad
people. Just to be
the defendant has spread lies about Lauren and talked to get
this part because she's been support of a plaintiff.
What? Why is this even being included? You're wasting there.
Hold on. I just wanted two things. There's two things. Uh, so
that's being included. Oh, defendants initial disclosure. So,
it would be pixy pixie side. Okay.
So this would be I see. So this would be that they're informing
him of these people who might have information. Lauren would
have been on that that's saying Lauren would be could be involved
in this case. Just warning you and you are continuously defaming
this person,
Yeah. Okay. There's two things that are happening here. Why I
think this is gross as a as a non- lawyer and a non-person or
whatever. Right. So maybe what I'm saying is there's two things
that are happening here. The first is a party I have no sympathy
for now, which is Pixie. You're wasting her time and you're destroying
her life because as as mired in conflict as I am right now, I
can still stream and make money and do all this. My guess is
Pixie is probably hanging on by a
Uh-huh. Do see how disingenuous and disgusting that this is actually
this is where I could actually get on like a little bit of a
rant about the how disgusting this person is. Why does he fain
concern for Pixie's privacy or her happiness or her well-being
in any way? Like, it's so disgusting and disingenuous for him
to do that, right? It's the same thing he did with, "Oh, a Abby
looked at my wife's journal. She looked at my wife's journal."
It's like,
sent you sent your wife's therapy document that analyzed like
all of the things that went wrong in her life to random anime
PFPs on Discord. You disgusting loser.
Why are you pretending to be concerned about Molina's privacy
right now? It's so performative. It's so weird. It's like so
It's like so inhuman. It's so lizardlike. Is actually cold blooded
based on the outcome of this particular Okay, that's my guess
just based on recent tweets I've seen from her that are all public.
Right. So the fact that you are wasting time from your client,
you're wasting time from your client to throw the journal was
shown to the time before the docu. That's not the pop-up book.
The pop-up book's a different thing. Robin random [__]
about again a nonparty to the case. Um Lauren Hayden has not
made any declarations to the court. She's not a witness to any
of this. She's not like why are you wasting your client's time
on this? Number one. And number two, the party that I by the
way when Pixie like posts that she's depressed or something,
right? When uh when Pixie posts about how she's depressed, if
you go look at that post in the replies, it's all DJers who are
shit-talking her, right? It's they're all DGers
just very obviously do have sympathy for is why are you wasting
the court's time with this like you're already elected to file
this in federal court. You wanted to go to big boy federal court.
So now we're on a federal docket eating through a federal judge's
time that I imagine probably have real cases to hear and important
[__] to hear even of these same cardi claims. Like
I said, if you go I'll just I'll just say that again through
this whole thing where he pretends that there's like no possible
case and there's no possible wrongdoing for this entire thing.
His only argument he he signed a statement saying, "Yes, I did
send that video non-consensually to some random person, but I
did it 6 months before she could hold me liable for it." Okay?
Like anybody who's who's arguing this on moral grounds, he literally
signed a statement saying he did the thing that he's being sued
for. Yes, I did do that thing. Yes, I did. I did do that thing.
That's that is not a matter of factual contention. Destiny's
lawyers will never argue. No, no, no. He's never sent this. They
have admitted it. It is already confessed. It is a mutually agreed
upon fact of this case.
want to read the So when he says there's nothing going on here,
right? Underlying case, the Giuliani defense. Yes, I lied, but
it's my first amendment right to lie.
These are some crazy cases. Like the defendants are genuinely
unhinged and crazy. But now you're wasting a judge's time to
go through your your your MySpace
posts. Like the is wrong. Why would you do this?
So now we we're going to go and bicker in front of a a federal
judge who's what supposed to play. It's just disgusting. It's
so gross to me. But
whatever. Again,
um as we'll get to at the end of this, obviously, as we went
through in the beginning, there's literally the the the chat
message from Abby to her friend saying, "Yeah, Destiny has sent
me like videos of his orbiters and acts like I don't know who
they are from his stream." Like that is what the message
says. Like and and then he's like, "You guys are crazy for acting
like there's a case here." Just because there's obvious proof
that I've admitted to that I sent it and there's circumstantial
evidence that I sent it to other people after Cardi came into
effect. That doesn't mean they should get to go through my videos
and see if I actually did it. That's disgust. That's the most
disgusting thing I've ever heard of in my life. Would your lawyers
have been able to file an objection to this motion if they had
file? Well, this isn't um I don't think this is a motion. This
is a filing in support of their other motion. Right. Motion for
protective order governing public commentary. Oh. Oh, this is
a gag order. This is a new motion. Damn, we got a lot of motion
in this case. Jesus Christ.
Why is Destiny so mad? I thought this was getting dismissed in
summary judgement. Hold on. Well,
this is from 2025, February 19th. I'm not sure. The majority
of this was pushed by Lauren Hayden. If I could get her disbar
for this considering she already failed
characterist Oh wait, hold on. That is actually he does just
name Lord. Oh, I didn't realize he was like using her full name
and trying to say it. Like he literally uses the full name. He
I don't
know, dude. That's what they mean. Okay. So, using her full name
in his chat and saying if I could get her disbarred. Okay. Okay.
So, he's conspir he's literally defaming Laura in his chat. File
her case on February 18th,
right? Why are you using the fact that you provided declarations
meaning I shouldn't be attacking Laura and then providing a statement
that I made before any of those
declarations had ever even been made?
That could be a good point if the uh if those declarations were
made uh later. Yeah, sure. Which I think that's entirely possible
they were. Let me see when were
they. I'm scrolling. Court listener. Give me a second.
Oh, initial
disclosures. Oh, were those made Oh, those were made way
later. Yeah, sure.
Oh, wait. Hold on. It's not in these disclosures. So, maybe it
is in his initial disclosures. I don't know when he did it. Jesus.
I His initial disclosures are not public from what I
tell. Also, the defendant has spread lies about Lauren. going
to talk about how we like to get this part because she's been
supportive of
plaintiff not because of the fact that she's you said I accused
her earlier of lying and all those things. Don't you think that
has more to do with I'm sure there are people that are supportive
of I just all all he has to do here is provide his evidence.
He's 99% sure this is all pushed by Lauren Hayden.
Evidence, please. Don't just
Can I get the Can I get the Yeah, I need the meme. Hold on. We
need this right now. This is This is unironically just doing
the meme directly. Like literally just tell me why you believe
this. Can I get any anything? Say what you want about Kiwi Farms.
Okay. They they cite some things. They they actually clip you
doing [__] They actually have evidence, right? This
is your evidence right now for like a bunch of the you say Lauren
de Laguna set this all up. She conspiring against me. I'm 99%
sure it was all her. We're excited
that there crackpipe.
Listen, the Vance ain't hitting quite right anymore. He's moved
on to actual meth. Okay, that's just the way it is. plaintiff
that I haven't bismerched. You want to be supportive of a plaintiff,
then whatever. Knock yourself out. I don't give a my issue with
the people,
brother. Brother Wicked Supreme made one off-handed remark about
him him liking Cosby and Louis CK and then liking Destiny later
in life. And you like actually tried to make him seem like a
creepy. That's a guy you were actually friends with cuz he made
one offcolor joke in my Discord.
Why are you acting like you aren't the most malicious on planet
Earth who are doing bad things?
Okay, not most in like the in like the online influencer sphere.
Furthermore, despite the protective order entered, I'm sure there's
some really anti-semitic people somewhere that are like very
evil. Okay, this this is a gag order. Hold on. Imagine the
audacity of trying to gag me after you made a public post detailing
everything about the case. This this is it's so disgusting.
Pick it up.
Oh. Oh, no. I'll tell them. Sorry. Audacity calling. Got it.
I've been saving that one for the perfect moment and that was
it. Imagine the audacity. Holy [__] I'm so [__]
I'm actually triggered. I want to do a public gag after you published
your whole ass instinct cuz now you're not happy that you didn't
find anything. Now you're not happy about the public filings.
Now you're not happy about the how the court case is going. Like
give me a break, dude. That's so wild.
But furthermore, despite the protective order entered by this
court to protect plaintiff Janeo's identity, defendant publicly
disclosed plaintiff's Jane Do's legal name on his YouTube platform.
First of all, I think this was literally the same day. Number
one, I removed that name. Number two, plaintiff literally listed
her name on the give sen go when they first
do you notice how like okay
when they published it. So the plaintiff has already made their
name public. They clearly didn't mean to do that. I I think they
it seems pretty clear they didn't mean to do that. All of the
damages associated with this case even have nothing to do with
plaintiff's name. It has everything to do with her identity which
is Pixie. And she's using her online name and everything again.
Uh I can't make the identity argument
Like all I feel like this entire court case is just like trying
to like lay traps and then see if I fall into the traps. And
it's
like like traps like when he said uh I have absolutely never
under under penalty of Persia, I've absolutely never sent that
video to anybody else. And then somebody comes forward with like
clearly they're like well Destiny deleted the video link actually.
But um I do have vlogs to these other people where I describe
these videos that nobody knew about two like a year and a half
before they ever came out.
Jesus that trap you not file this motion at the start of the
case. True. There's a lot of stuff they like the TRO for instance
that they should
have. Um I don't know why this is getting filed later. I'm guessing
her lawyers are yeah like pinned for time or something. I don't
know what the [__] is going on with them.
But lots of the content or lots of the conduct isn't until like
a couple weeks ago, right? Him going after the lawyers isn't
until a couple weeks ago. Him going after Abby isn't until a
couple weeks ago. After plaintiff brought this to the attention
of the court in her reply to the opposition or motion preliminary
junction, the defendant removed the reference plane. However,
defendant did not delete another reference he made to her name
at minute
11:34. Why then? Why not ask me? Meet and confer. If you know
there are additional mentions, I deleted the one they asked.
If there were additional mentions, then just request it. It'll
get deleted. What? Do you think I want to mention? No. This is
a spite. Why would you Again, why would you hold on to this
for Dude, I don't I don't know why. Why is he assuming they held
on to it? Why wouldn't it just be, oh, somebody like went and
searched it again and let them know later or something? Why is
it all like a malicious plan to to malign him to him over
4 months? You actually gave a about your identity. Why are you
holding on to this? Moreover, in the chat thread that accompanies
this video, after 758, his followers then repeatedly refer to
Pliff's name. Why are you listing this in a public filing if
you give a about your
name? Um, I'm guessing, well, I'm I'm guessing the point is that
you're not taking any actual initiative in doing this, in like
trying to protect this. And it's also good evidence that you
are not the only person that when you do this, when you do this
performative thing on screen, you're actually training a whole
bunch of other people to do it as well, right? And that's a part
of their argument is you have a massive audience and you you
get that audience to go after people to to continue to spread
these messages you're
doing. So, so like I could theoretically I guess I won't show
it on stream although I don't know why not because it's all in
a public
filing. I think he's assuming or they might be assuming you'll
take it down or do something about it, but hard to
say. Why would you include this? So now that you're just Why
would you do this? What the?
Oh my god.
Defendant did not remove those comments containing plaintiff's
name and so they are still public. These actions are meant to
defeat the protections afforded to plaintiff of filing as a Jane
Doe. You defeated those protections when you literally launched
a Substack
identifying yourself in the videos and then launched a G send
that was attached to your real life name that was all public
facing. No, I I don't believe you forfeit your right to privacy
because of a mistake. And I'd say probably even trying to like
actually push people to look at those things is probably another
way of getting around it, right? He's going to go live on stream.
He's going to say, "But you publish it this way, but you you
put your real name over here. You put your real name over there.
You put your real name over here and
there. Come on. Give me a
break. This video has been viewed over 130,000 times. And the
same um it was after that message to him about our emotional
distress. And I would imagine if he wanted to challenge that,
right? He probably should have challenged that when they applied
for those things and opposed those back then. Thought dude is
nonentual. I don't think I don't think anything's changed since
then. Then mocks and ridicules her. He then tells his father's
motive solely for the purpose of extorting him.
Well,
technically there was another person that claimed that in response
to Pixie's measures to them, but yeah. Now, don't hate the
messenger. Cool. Destiny and President Sunday best buddies. Destiny
and President Sunday best friends forever. Let's go.
I thought I thought when Sunday called Destiny fat and disgusting
with like a really gross patchy beard that when Sunday repeatedly
pointed out how how patchy Destiny's beard was. I thought he
got put on the Omega blacklist, but apparently they're close
enough now that Destiny's just like, "What's up, Sunday? We best
buds." Numerous individuals initially contacted Plaintiff with
information pertinent to this action, but have refused to provide
testimony due to fear of retaliation and or dox what I can I
make up. Where's my lawyer? Can I just Am I allowed to just say
this? I've had 50 different people tell me that plaintiff is
actually engaged in all sorts of, but they don't want if none
of this happened. I hope he realizes that the identities wouldn't
be kept from his lawyers like in any case. I don't believe they
could, I believe, be kept from him. The the lawyers could be
ordered not to give the identities to him, but those identities
would be on the record. And if any of those people were lying,
they would be open to subpoena. they would be open to being uh
to having their log subpoenaed or whatever. If any of those people
were lying or making things up about them, they would be open
up to the same opened up to the same penalties by participating
in the case that anybody else would. They can't participate without
their names. The penalties for them lying would be the same as
penalties for anybody else. Why is he pretending that there wouldn't
be a penalty? There would be no consequence to just making something
up. What does he think they just added a bunch of things into
the law that you could just make allegations and nobody could
possibly punish you for them and you just withdraw them? No.
No judge could go, "Wait, wait, hold on. Did you have a reason
to make that allegation?" I I don't understand. There's like
such an obvious loop. There'd be such an obvious loophole that
would the whole justice system. Why does he think that that's
the way it works? Want to say it. They don't actually want to
come. Well, sorry. That's That question answers itself. He doesn't
think it's the way that it works. He just knows that he can say
whatever he he wants to this gaggle of clapping seals, these
clapping seals, and they will go that totally made it up about
you. until they make it
to tell me the joke about his [__]
again. Forward and identify themselves. They don't actually want
to put that in writing anywhere. This is hearsay. And in some
cases, this is double hearsay. Like why? Like they're not even
present. See exhibit A. Besides the three witnesses who have
provided declarations under seal, by the way, none of those three
witnesses, well, technically one of them is actually relevant
to the case, but no evidence has been provided for anything they've
Oh. Uhoh.
Oh, I guess did he did he actually not read this stuff before
he went live? He just decided to go live and
the original. God, it's going to be such a good summer. I can
feel it. Do you guys feel the energy in the air that it's going
to be a good summer? We're going to have a great time. It's just
going to be I think it's going to be awesome. I don't know how
this case is going to go. I can just feel like I just feel like
there's some energy in the air that I I just know it's going
to be a good summer. You guys ever feel that? I can feel it's
like uh it's hot in my place. I don't have the air conditioning
on. It's like humid. It's hot. Uh I have the the window open.
Um I can hear the crickets outside. I can just feel it's just
the energy of the it's it's infecting me. I'm just I'm I don't
know, man. It's going to be good. It's going to be great. Multitude
of individuals who initially contacted Plaintiff. There are now
only
three with whom plaintiff still has contact because the majority
deleted their accounts after Destiny posted his video on YouTube
titled Destiny addresses his lawsuit on February. Wait, so you're
telling me that you made a Substack in January. You had people
contact you.
Yeah. You didn't take down any names. You didn't take down any
statements.
probably they took down statements and whatever names those people
were willing to give. Lots of those people opened up. I I'm sure
I could find some of these statements. I kept logs of a bunch
of these things, but like these people said, "Hey, please never
leak this." I'm terrified of what this guy would
do. I'm like terrified of what this guy
do. That's that's just what they do, man. That's that's how it
was. They people message me. I had people message me from like
multiple accounts where they would be like, "Hey, here's like
a little bit here. Hey, here's a little bit here. I'm really
worried about this." And then they go away for a while. They
deactivate their account or something. They message me on a different
account. Even people I knew. I had people I knew. I knew their
identity. I knew them. I'd had conversations with them who messaged
me from fake accounts to be like, "Hey, I don't really want to
talk about this, but like I don't want this tied to my identity,
but like here's what I got told. Here's like what I was sent."
Yeah, that that absolutely happened. I just
You didn't sign any affidavit. You didn't verify anything they
said. Then you filed a court case and you went back to look for
them and their accounts were gone. Are you crazy? This is insane.
Do you even know if these people were
real? Yes.
Yep. Or were they? And he docks those people. Well, uh I mean
he definitely points people at Kiwi Farms, too. some docs that
are on Kiwi Farms of people who came forward as witnesses. Or
is it literally did Kiwi Farms literally troll this into filing
a court case? Are you [__] ser?
Oh, that's actually I don't know if you can do that. No, no,
you must be able to get people to sign affidavit. But yeah, you'd
have to file a court case and you'd have to retain legal counsel.
But yeah, I think um they had what do you call it? They had like
the proof that it was sent. They had proof that there was a huge
pattern. Once you have proof that it was sent once and you have
a huge pattern of people getting all kinds of videos of all b
a whole bunch of different women. By the way, if you've ever
sent a video to Destiny or received a video from Destiny, you're
probably getting non-conensually sent to you, right? Not sent
to you
Non-consensually sent to you like like it was incredibly pervasive.
Okay. So, just, you know, if you happen to be watching this for
some reason on YouTube, yeah, you're probably in the group of
people who got sent stuff that there was not consent for that
to be sent to you. Serious right
now. So, anyway, massive pattern and the proof of it being sent
in the Rose thing. I think that's enough to file the case and
and continue to talk to people.
absolutely. Yeah, I don't think that's crazy at all. Wait, you're
on YouTube? I am not. But I assume when I do Destiny stuff, Riyle
tends to post that stuff. So I just assume with this it'll get
posted.
The god three individuals with whom plaintiff still has contact
have told that they're afraid of speaking out or
because I see I see Stacia as her online name and I see Hannah
posting every single day in other people's Discord chats about
all of this. They're clearly not. Oh, my ears are burning. What
Discord? What Discord? Could he just say discord.gg/jlk? Could
he help a brother out? Help a brother out. Um I don't know, he's
like probably trying to remember that. Like he's he's acting
like you guys uh didn't know each other, right? It's it's very
strange. It's very
strange. And here here's my one skitso theory of the day. Okay,
I'll throw this out there. The one skitso theory. I don't want
to be a total [__] about it, but like
realistically, he probably saw some Twitter post or some message
you sent saying it's kind of annoying that they can't get my
name right and did that. I'm telling you, that's like the level
of petty he is. He probably saw some like some Discord post or
some Twitter post where you were like, it's weird that they can't
get my name right and he was like Stoia, whoever that is. He's
a
petty. Yep. is a petty contact have told her after that they
are afraid of speaking out or testifying against cynic because
I see I see Stacia is her online name Stacia and I see Hannah
posting every single day in other people's discord chats about
all of this they're clearly not afraid they're clearly not intimidated
they talk all the time about this constantly they can't help
themselves they can't help themselves but constantly talk about
all of this what are you talking about
uh that overt dummy you just messaged me. That's probably from
the case, just so you know. That's probably just from the case.
Um,
okay. What am I trying to think of? I just had something to say.
God damn it. I got sent to Discord about this constantly. They
can't help themselves. They can't help themselves, but constantly
talk about all of this. I would imagine people who like had an
intimate relationship with you that they thought you like cared
about them or had like you know positive feelings concern were
concerned for their well-being or their futures or anything and
then realized that you were sending that you shot with them to
other people without their consent. They probably had a pretty
harsh like meeting with reality. It was probably pretty up and
they probably don't like
you. They just probably don't like you, bro. I don't know what
to tell you. What? What am I What else am I supposed to say?
Obviously, they think you
suck. Yeah, they might talk about it. I don't know why that's
weird. And I don't know who this is with whom plaintiffs still
contact have told her they are afraid of speaking out or testifying
against. Okay, so this would be probably be the people who haven't
testified, right? I would imagine. What are you talking
about? Jesus.
Does he realize that it's even worse that he is doing that doing
this bad to people and cares so little about them that he can't
remember their names? Doesn't make him look better. Uh yeah.
No, no doubt that he like had like a relationship with this person
where he talked to them like fairly often all the time um with
like these people, right? And then he's pretending he doesn't
even know them, pretending that they like didn't matter. It's
like yeah, that would actually be worse. That would be worse,
Destiny. That you had no concern for these people at all. That
you can't even remember their names. makes you look like a again
like a sort of like inhumane lizard
person. Disgusting. Cold blooded. Federal rule of civil 2016
specifically authorized the court for good cause issue an order
to protect a party or person from annoyance. Uh I'm going to
skip through this stuff because it's just this is not really
Are you exhibit A before finishing? Why I'm trying to what are
are you
spoiling? Hold on. I'm getting water. I Jane Do declares follows.
I'm over the Who is
this? I won't say the name, but I'm curious. Did we actually
get any copies of any of these or am I going into my hearing
tomorrow with absolutely no idea who any of these people are?
Let's
see. Don't have it there. What about this is Hold on. Is there
not only one Jane Doe? I thought there was um like when they
say Jane Doe with no other clarification, I believe that's Jane
Doe. There's only one Jane Doe with regards to this case. Nope.
That's redacted. That's the Jane Doe. Can you just start reading
for two seconds?
Redacted. Redacted for two seconds. Great. That's nice. Cool.
So, I get to go into this here. I have no idea who any of these.
Okay, cool. Base. Let's see what they say.
Dude, thank God for this case. He's going to sense so much on
butt plugs because he is so eternally ass pained every time he
looks at this case. It's like he's plugged up right now. He didn't
even put it in. He's just infinitely ass pained. Just read the
idiot. Put the dock in the bag in the Put the fries in the bag,
Lobo. Put the the legal dock in the bag. Just read it. We'll
all be fine. You'll be okay. It'll soothe you. Just go. No. Maybe
I can figure it out.
Little publicly. I misspoke. Okay, that's not exhibit A. You
can't hang around for Dan. You can't hang around with Dan for
as long as I did and not misspeak occasionally. Oh, exhibit A's
down here. Oh, too late. We're reading this anyway now.
Personal matters here. I called it. I'm testifying in declaration
in support of Lind's motion protective order to govern you. I
can contest the fact that um defendant Steven Bonell's actions
hearing the willingness of witnesses to come forward and testify
in this action when I Oh, this is just Pixie.
Yeah, Jane. Why does she not say she am I not allowed to use
the online name anymore?
No, you are my first online name is included. of 2025 that I
would be taking legal action against the defendant. Numerous
individuals contacted me with information they believed was current
to the case. The majority of these individuals informed me that
the defendant is now we have to we have to all pretend every
DJer. Okay, Destiny, that's Jane Doe. Read exhibit A. Okay. Well,
the zip zip guy is saying like obviously this is who it is. Okay.
All right. Maybe that guy's not as but like do we all just pretend
he didn't just go on a whole rant about how it's soed up that
they keep redacting these names I have no idea who they are individuals
without consider that has nothing to do with the case that's
not pertinent that's not relevant to this case why are you even
including this one of these individuals whose screen name
xxx told me the defendant sent the video depicting me to their
sister is this double here say
What? This individual and their sister as well as other individuals
who initially hunted me completely deleted their accounts. Dude,
are you actually
Um, I mean, this isn't really like strong evidence, but it is
evidence. It is like why they initially filed with the stuff
that they did, right? This is a this is this was a part of the
initial
Uh, Crazy Monk 27. No, you are wrong. For those pieces of evidence
to be considered by the jury, they would have to be given as
affidavit. You can't just do hearsay. They would have to give
affidavit statements under penalty of perjury. Otherwise, they're
not even being included on the record. They won't be presented
to a jury. If this sister thing never pans out and is never anything,
it will not be presented to a jury at all.
Destiny has like invented this fiction in completely cognitively
people's heads and unfortunately they they continue to come here
and like
spew this will not be presented to a jury. It will not be considered
evidence. It's in here because I don't know why Pixie included
it to be honest. It's in her statement. I don't know why but
it's there. This can't be real, right? This has to Yes. Sorry.
The affidavit would be under would be at risk of perjury. But
I'm saying that the thing where Pix, somebody messaged Pixie
on Discord and said, "Hey, my sister got this video." That won't
be presented to a jury unless that is uh backed up by an affidavit
or backed up by some kind of Discord logs, evidence, that kind
of
right? Those won't be presented to the jury. Be a joke. This
individual and their sisters, as well as other individuals who
had initially contacted him, completely deleted their accounts
after Destiny posted his video on YouTube entitled Destiny Addresses
Lawsuit on February
2025. I I I legitimately You know what?
props props to you know what the farmers are brave people then
why present it if it will never be I don't know why they're presenting
it here I think they included it because they thought basically
they were going to get a statement from this person right so
they included in the initial complaint as one of the things that
they were include like they said this is why we believe it falls
under Cardi yeah it's in support of the motion oh no no hold
on oh sure this is now this is now evidence that these things
happened saying this motion is about hey people are scared this
is now evidence of them being scared and it is evidence of that
true but it was included in the initial complaint it is evidence
of this actually yeah I don't know why you're right latigious
gamer it is saying that like these people came forward offered
evidence and then deleted their account it's weak evidence right
it's not I wouldn't say that you would grant the motion based
on this but it is a part of the motion it is a piece of evidence
in good job support of the motion it was an epic troll epic troll
In this video, the defendant further violates my privacy publishing.
There's almost 1 million followers. Out of context, private messages.
Oh, I'm sorry. Do we need more context with the
messages? Crazy monk 27. You have absolutely no idea what you're
talking about. You are clearly cognitively. You probably still
hang out in Destiny all the time. I don't know why you're in
here concern trolling. Have a good one. Out of context. I'm sorry.
Is Hassan suing me now?
The three women that provided declarations under seal and sort
of plain dismotion for learning. Sorry, I'm like I'm really just
like done with the people who come in. They're like, "Well, I
you know, it seems to me that like everybody kind of up here."
No, you just don't pay any attention. You're totally mentally.
Just walk away. Don't watch. You don't have to watch. You could
just walk away and save your dignity. Don't come here and concern
troll. Loser
junction expressed fear of being publicly targeted or doxed by
defendant and or his followers and indicated they're unwilling
to participate in dis I just does this loser who comes in and
types the random concern trolling the chat does he not understand
that Destiny literally if you if you actually morally care about
sending to other people without their consent that Destiny's
already admitted he signed he he swore in a statement okay he
signed an affidavit saying I sent that video it was just 6 months
before Cardi but I totally did send it I totally did it without
consent. Yep. Yep. Discovery or testify unless her identities
remain confidential. Well, but two of these people, the Hannah
person,
um, for this reason, the witness declarations are filed under
seal. Well, Hannah's wasn't. And then you put the screen names
of Bro, this is so Oh my god, dude. Get me out of here. Get me
the out of They talk about this daily. I have so many um I have
so many screenshots, too. That's going to be wild. So, here are
the people, by the way, who are afraid of um talking about the
about testifying
because their legal names could be included in the case and they
don't want to testify with their legal names protected. Again,
he's he's doing the the conflation of legal name and pseudonym
that he refuses to admit is real, but no, everybody knows is
real. But let me tell you, judge, your honor, look at all the
testimony that they're okay leaving in this other dude's Discord
server. H
Besides uh Oh, wait, wait, wait. Oh,
says there are four additional witnesses I have contact with.
But they have told me that they are afraid of speaking out or
testifying against the defendant because of his likely retaliation
and harassment. Attached here to as exhibit A is a true and correct
copy of one of the witnesses named XXX who has communicated to
me her fear of defendant. Okay. Exhibit A.
You dox fans randomly. No.
Wait, why is he avoiding saying your name now? Uh, I think it's
because Well, it's totally disingenuous, but I think it's cuz
they're implying that um his threats to me were bad. Wait, hold
on. X who has communicated to me her fear of defendant. Okay,
exhibit A.
It's just that I don't have money for a lawyer or anything. Once
he knows my name or something, I'm afraid he's going to harass
me or get others do something.
What What would they even need a lawyer for if they're just a
witness or
They don't want you to get their name. That's what they just
said. As you constantly pointed out that even if things were
filed under seal, you should still get their name. Yeah, they're
very worried that with that name he will do
this is on January 22nd before I even released that YouTube video
as well as initially haunting me completely deleted their accounts
ever posted this YouTube video on February 20th. They literally
told That's one of the pe That's one of the people who didn't
delete, right?
22nd. What? I That was one of the people she was still in contact
with. What even is this screenshot? What is this? I I don't know.
I can't know who these people are. I'm not random. Why do they
keep filing secret evidence? Ignore everything. I'm so Okay,
this is the difference between being Why do they keep filing
secret evidence?
Street smart and being books smart. Okay, cuz I read all this
boring stupid legal, okay? But then when you look at how Trump's
lawyers argue, the solicitor general argues in front of the Supreme
Court, okay? Or you see these arguments, none of that actually
matters. Okay? All of that was And why are you pretending you
belong in this field or with these names or these people in any
way? These people that you're naming right now are all far more
educated than you. You've read a couple Wikipedia articles. You've
used some not not unlike me, by the way. I probably have less
legal experience than Destiny. Okay? I don't know if I could
argue. Listen,
I'm like 1,000th of a lawyer. Destiny is like 3 1000 of a lawyer.
Okay? Like we're we're legally I admit that. I don't know why
he's like these these people argue before the Supreme Court.
I was like, "Brother, you are you are an uneducated. Stop pretending
you know
anything." Like, and by the way, unless Pixie's lawyers are severely
reprimanded and sanctioned for their conduct in that magistrate
hearing tomorrow, unless I'm not saying that the judge goes,
"Hey, you should have done this. Hey, that's bad." If they aren't
like hit with actual serious sanctions, he you you can't take
him seriously anymore, right? you you you literally can't take
him seriously at all. I don't know if he thinks like later when
he's like, "Well, I'm not sure that they will be sanctioned after
he's gone on like a multi-hour rant about how these people are
the most disgusting people he's ever met and they will be saying
they're they're just terrible people. They they need to be sanctioned.
They can't they shouldn't even be doing this. They're so unqualified
to practice law." If if it goes through with nothing, he looks
like a complete fool. Now, I think there's it's possible the
judge would go, "Hey, you should have sent them the names or
something." I think that's the most likely outcome. He's still
the same overconfident 15-year-old libertarian who reads Atlas
Shrugged and understood economics better than anyone. Yeah, that's
basically that's some that basically summarizes his entire career,
right? But he Hey, I'll give him this. He's incredibly good at
optics. He like he makes it look like he knows very well what
he's talking about, right? He's basically just extremely skilled
at making other people look bad. That's like what he does most
of the time. All of it was
This is street law. This is the real [__] I have
no idea what this message is. I don't know who it's sent. I don't
even know who it's about. It doesn't even mention my name. I
I don't worry about the timer. I'll just put the timer away.
We don't need a timer. We're just watching this.
Uh yeah, F. Listen, if he's 100% right, then I have to come on
my stream. I'm not going to quit streaming if he's 100% correct.
I'm not. I'm going to have to come on and just be like, "Wow,
Pixie's lawyers just got disbarred. I look like
idiot." But I listen, I just assume he'd be making some slightly
better arguments if that were the case, right? I just I think
there'd be slightly better arguments. He wouldn't look so It
wouldn't be so embarrassing to listen to.
Dude, the hand flailing in
this What are this? Totally random. It's totally rand. You guys
can't see me flame flailing my hands around, but it's totally
random, guys. It's totally
Apparently, they use the word gaslighting. Uh, can they do that
legally? Are they allowed to use gaslighting as a term?
Destiny has tried to repeatedly dox one of these witnesses whose
screen name is X after he publicly expressed his support for
me. This potential witness will not testify to pertinent information
regarding the case unless his information can be protected. Blank
is expected to be providing any further information after defendant
publicly called for his death on the defendant's YouTube channel.
Why would you Okay, so it's either So it's it's one of two
Yeah, I think so. It's pretty obvious that that's like me or
maybe one of four. Me, Queen, Laugh, Mr. Girl, right? It's pretty
obvious. Now, let's keep that in mind. Okay, let's keep that
in mind for a little bit later. Attached to his exhibit B is
a true and correct copy of his communication to me expressing
his fear defendant. Let's see if we can figure out who this one
is.
Oh. Ah, good
times. How do you do anything but laugh? How do you do anything
but laugh
there? It's funny. Okay, this could be the best part of the stream.
He does get up and walk away. Um, but I will
say, hold on. Do not redact her own nickname, and we all know
it's Yeah. Uh, the name is attached to the lawsuit, and I literally
don't care about my pseudonym being attached at all. I've never
cared. I literally, if I could give a statement, he's he is right.
They won't take affidavit from people under pseudonyms, right?
So, I said, which I came on stream and said, by the way, that
if they can protect my legal name, then I will give a statement.
And if they can't protect my legal name, I will not give a statement.
That's how it is. Okay? This out here saying
these morons who have nothing to live for, okay? Extremely low
IQ, worship this guy like he's a god, and have basically nothing
to live for. I don't want my legal name out there at
Props to giving the statement. Uh I have not given the state.
I don't know if this order is going through. If they get this
gag order and whatever the gag order and um and they can file
those things under seal, yeah, I'll give them the statement.
But I'm not I'm not doing it. But I'm I already said, yeah, I'm
not doing that with him like telling people they should kill
me.
That sorry, we should get through to whenever he comes back.
gone for a minute.
Sorry, I didn't mean to skip through too
There we go. Be
back. You know, uh they listen if they came up and like actually
wanted to fight or something maybe. Although there like I don't
I might be okay cuz most of the fitness guys are in my community
now, but like I I don't know. I don't listen. There's going to
be some inshaped DJs. There's going to be like some bro look
at Gojo. If Gojo If Gojo came for me, that would be up. I would
I would not stand a
chance. Okay, there's going to be some like lifting incels who
would be in insane shape.
Okay, I'm not taking the
risk. Like, it's only funny because I'm rich. Like, dude, if
I if I was in this financial or the financial position I was
in like even like 5 years ago, this would be legitimately like
a horrific experience. This is just like this is insane. Oh,
wait. I thought it was already the most disgusting horrific experience
you've ever been through. Was it Is it not the most disgusting
horrific thing that's ever happened to you? Or did that change?
Also, like this is funny.
I I I I wish I knew more of like the sanctional arguments like
her attorneys I think should be like severely reprimanded because
let's assume that this was an ordinary Cardier case. Let's assume
this was a case where this federal law is usually invoked. I've
said this before. I think we've gone through one or two of these
on stream. Somebody can link me a card as they want. The defendants
are actually crazy. These men are insane. They're shooting these
videos um sometimes on alternate accounts to plaintiffs friends,
family members, co-workers. They're crazy. A lot of these defendants
are right crazy. If you want to litigate a case like this, involves
relatively sensitive information. If you're not qualified to
do the case, then pass it over to someone who is. There must
be some rule against like if I let's say I go to the University
of Law School of Nebraska and I pass the bar or whatever and
then some guy like says, "Can you be my defendant for like a
quadruple homicide case?" And I don't even know anything about
I was like, "Yeah, let's do like I'm pretty sure you can. I think
that's like a I don't think you can do that. You must not be
able to." I'm saying I I think the only qualification they have
for practicing law is that you pass the bar, right? Like if somebody
couldn't afford an attorney, isn't that the whole point of like
I'm I'm pretty sure I I don't get it. I I just don't get
it. What he just said applies to him. uh friends, family, and
co-workers. Oh, I wasn't I'll be honest. I was not necessarily
listening for this past I was getting another time stamp. Hold
on. Let me go back. Experience. My bad.
I I tapped out there for a second. I got I wish I knew more of
like the sanctional arguments. Like her attorneys, I think, should
be like severely reprimanded because let's assume that this was
an ordinary Cardi case. Let's assume this was a case this federal
law is usually invoked. Oh, those guys are crazy. I think we've
gone through one or two of these strings. Let me get one. The
defendants are actually crazy. These men are insane. They're
shooting these videos on alternate accounts to plaintiffs friends,
family members, co-workers. They're Oh, see, no, Riy, you said
it was the same, right? He was shooting the video of his friends
and family and co-workers. Okay, that's what he he was shooting
the video of his friends, families, and co-workers to other people,
not to those people. Key key distinction. You were very close,
but not quite crazy. A lot of these defendants are right. If
you want to litigate a case like uh true actually Carrick true
he was sending yeah there was a lot of uh he was also sending
it to them. Yeah, true. That is involves relatively sensitive
information. If you're not qualified to do the case, then pass
it over to someone who is there must be some rule against like
if I let's say I go to the University of Law School of Nebraska
and I the performative concern again, right? The performative
concern like he gives a about other people. Oh my god, there's
just if this if this if I were actually a monster that did the
things they accused me of, which they've accused him of going
live on his stream and publicly maligning the people involved
in the case to his massive audience and opening them up to harassment.
He's he's actively in the process of doing that. While he's saying,
"If I was the monster they painted me as, if I was really what
they accused me of being, you've done every behavior they actually
pointed out in this stream so far in the last 30 minutes, 60
minutes. car or whatever and then some guy like says, "Can you
be my defendant for like a quadruple homicide case?" And I don't
even know anything about like, "Yeah, let's do like I'm pretty
sure you can. I think that's like a I don't think you can do
that. You must not be able to." I'm saying, "I think I'm just
relying on common." He's relying on common sense. Does Destiny
understand that you're allowed to represent yourself in court?
Does Destiny understand that you're allowed to choose the representation
you want? What What common sense is he referring to?
How would there be a law against somebody who is literally past
the bar representing someone else when a person can actually
self-represent? It sounds like it. Maybe you can. Like this is
like imagine if I was the bar like if I was the unhinged person.
Oh, it's so sad. I see names sometimes. MVT77 was like in here
and he was cool and he's just I said this though. I told you
guys this that there would be people who literally like can't
actually survive without hearing Destiny's voice and it would
be a very painful journey to go from like to to go to not hearing
it and a lot of them weren't going to make it. I just very sad.
I just get very sad that these people say that I was. You've
leaked so many identities to me. You've leaked so many of these
identities and you're not even using the correct blackout
again tools. You're not even using the right. It looks like you
did. They color over this with a marker and then MVT was a mod
here. Yeah. Yeah.
I don't know. Is he pretending that um it wouldn't be obvious
from this that it's me?
I don't even know if they actually just
I don't understand if he's pretending that it wouldn't be obvious
from this and the the this has to be set up, right? The only
reason why they're doing this is Yeah. I think the whole case
is just trying to get me to cuz they know they have no case.
So, it's just wasting my time, wasting my money, destroying my
reputation, trying to destroy my life. It's just that's the goal.
It's It is act It is literally I as much as I hate to say it,
it is the red pill nightmare scenario of like the actual hardest
case scenario of that. Why the hardest? He's going to be raped.
Are you guys Are you guys actually ready for Destiny to go on
the Whatever podcast and it's going to be him and him and Andrew.
Okay. Him and Andrew Wilson arguing against some feminists and
being like, "Oh, you think you think she wasn't just a gold digger?
You think she's not just a gold digger?" Well, let me tell you
something.
Why did they black out her avatar but not
redacted? I don't want to say his
Do you mind if if I say I sat down with your attorneys? Yeah,
sure. What day? What for? Exactly.
I just wanted to say it today. Bretter just filed a motion in
opposition and I'm going to say this is precisely why I refused
to give an affidate because Dr. himself is saying calling for
my death is too much. Wait, are is are is are they plotting and
scheming behind the scenes on how to
h and she's trying to gag me?
What? Where's the plotting and scheming against me while she's
literally working behind the scenes with this guy to try to optimize
for his coverage?
Pixie didn't message me. I messaged Pixie and said, "Hey, do
you mind if I say sit down with your attorneys cuz I'm going
to do the I
I Dude, I don't even What is happening?
I I literally was like, "Hey, um I don't know if you like want
if you don't want me to do this. If you don't want me to mention,
I won't." But like I do you mind if I say this cuz I just want
to say like this is actually why I I wouldn't do it. It's like
this guy's calling for my death. Obviously is up. You understand?
I I'm not going to I'm not going to risk my identity getting
put on paper when he's calling for my death. That's like too
much. Sorry. I feel like Ethan Klein, dude. This is Oh, he's
having a schizophrenic meltdown. biggest um like paranoia conspiracy,
right? Although I already had this basically confirmed on the
day that the gift send me go was made and I saw Lauren's name
on I was like, "Ah, that makes sense, right?"
Uhhuh. Jesus Christ.
I Yeah, he is just with absolutely
um sorry this is a joke I got before this as well.
It's very interesting to see him so confused right now because
he can't identify what is happening here. It's a mysterious phenomenon
that he has never before considered. I showed up and I said I
I did something he he would never have thought to do. I asked
for consent. I know. I know. Crazy crazy move. Okay. Absolutely
wild. I was like, "Hey, do you mind if I do this? Hey, can I
can I can I do you mind if I do this thing?" Oh, yeah. Okay.
Oh, nice. Nice. He's like, "Oh, that's what is is that what explicit
consent looks like?" Oh. Oh, is saying my cell plus destiny call.
He's he's literally like one of the androids from um from Westworld.
Okay. He sees a screenshot of somebody asking for explicit consent
and he's like, "Doesn't look like anything to me. It's a conspiracy."
Why? I have no idea what's going on. That's too much. But I've
already if I've already done this, then why do you even care?
What? Like, your honor, um, it's just very obvious. Uh, you failed
dox me. I'm not going to dox my legal name in this
okay? And open myself up to actually getting harassed in real
life. No thank you. No thank you. No thank you. You've you've
literally tried to You tried to dox me and then call for my death.
I do not want to actually dox myself in these public documents
and make that a reality
you with my legal
name. I don't think this is confusing to anybody with, you know,
two brain cells to rub together for a spark. It's apparently
It's not I'm sure it's not confusing to him. He's trying to present
it as confusing so that when he goes when he goes, I can't think
of any reason this would happen. I Why would this actually be
a problem for you? It's actually for all of the again clapping
seals over here. He can convince them that there's nothing they
could possibly think of, right? Because they'll never ever consider
something that Destiny hasn't told them they should consider.
It's it's like actually just a blind spot. He's creating blind
spots for them. Yes. My name is Steven Bunell and I'm from Miami,
Florida. What brings you to court today? Your honor, I Steven
Bunell, who lives in Miami, Florida, does not wish to give any
more commentary on this because I don't want people to know my
name or my address. Thank you, sir. You're
Like, stalker show this on stream today. What did he say? Oh,
this is the best part. This is the best
part. What did he say? I think he thought Did he think I was
going to like moralize about this or say it wasn't a mistake
or
I actually don't know what he thought.
This just shows This just shows Jtock is
lie. Whoa, it's Kyle. This just shows Jtock is gonna lie because
I asked Pixie if she minded if I said that uh I talked to her
attorneys, asked for consent to mention that on stream, and then
went on my stream and said, "Hey, uh tying my legal name to this
case when Desi's calling for my death would be concerning to
me."
It's literally
It's It's I don't Okay, continuing. Sorry. We got to go to the
best part of the stream. One second. Are they taking turns getting
the 10-page motion?
This is them admitting to just go lying,
Um, they're like trying to get performatively outraged for him
ahead of time. This isn't proof of him lying,
Oh, why are you assuming this first statement is a lie? Do you
mind if I say I sat down with your attorneys? I don't know if
this Oh, this is him implying that he actually hasn't sat down
with his attorneys or her attorneys. It could just be him saying,
"Can I have permission to say this on stream?"
Yeah. What down with your attorneys? I don't know if this is
him implying that he actually hasn't sat down with his attorneys
or her attorneys. It could just be him saying, "Can I have permission
to say this on stream?" Yes. And then he has to like think. He's
like, "Wait, is that is that
Yeah, I'm just asking for permission."
Oh, no. I know he's considering what bit of an assumption here,
but I'm so curious
if Lauren is the one that's
quarterbacking this
because he he he was so close to the truth. Huh? Huh? You know,
maybe
maybe Trump just lost the election. Or Hold on, hold on. Wait.
I just had a thought. I just had a
George Soros is probably actually quarterbacking this whole thing.
He asked her a question. Do you mind if I make a public statement
about the case? And she answered that statement in one minute.
How did she know the answer to that? So, I imagine that she'd
probably text or email her lawyer and ask, "Is it okay if this
guy makes this statement with regards to Destiny or whatever?"
Or it might just be, "What if somebody else has asked if they
could mention that they spoke to her lawyers or something?" What
if she just knows that you can't actually tell them no that it's
like no you can't talk about this anywhere. I don't know. I don't
know. Does that look good? Hey, could I s could I tell somebody
that I talked to your lawyers? No. Shut the up. I don't know if
you can I don't know if you can do that. But they answer
How? It's so funny. It's so funny. How is chat? They just all
take like Q's, right? They all take Q's like little drones. Susi
sus
sus. This is the you he that used to make him uh fun to This
is the [__] that used to make him fun to watch, but
with the wool pulled back, it's just so cringe at Jar. I know.
I know. But here's the thing. in a lot of other cases. Now, I
can't say for sure with like uh the Mr. Girl thing and a lot
of these other cases, I think like with the election stuff, with
the Trump stuff, it's like he's usually arguing on the side of
right, right? Like he is actually making like morally correct
arguments. He he used to do that quite often. He would make like
the morally correct argument. And then you could say, well, he's
offensive and he's rude and he's like bordering on like um on
being psychopathic, but he's doing it for the sake of good. And
now that sake of good thing is just totally gone, right? And
he's like probably logically in the wrong in a in a lot of these
cases as well. It's like he he can't stand on like the logical
footing. He can't stand on the moral high ground. He's got like
no
footing. Uh Mark Carney, I agree with the first statement. I
probably I agree. I don't think Max is like a bad person. Um
I would agree that he's a better person than Destiny
2, for sure.
I don't know if I could just say like blanket Max is a good person
with like the story and stuff, but like I I don't know. I I talked
to Max,
so I I don't think Max is like uh I do think I do think I would
qualify him as like a far better person than Destiny. Obviously,
this is them explicitly saying they're falsifying a claim of
Wait, how is it saying
that? He's like, I don't see it, but you have me intrigued. Could
you You're telling me there's a Kraken here. Can you point the
I don't see the Kraken, but I do want to know. She sat down with
the attorneys. He's asking Chill to let a stream know. Well,
no. I understand. That's what I am interpreting this as. But
why was she able to answer in the affirmative in one minute here?
Would she have actually cleared it with her lawyer first, though?
I thought about that. But what what what would that even look
like? Do you think that if you ask a lawyer, hey, just checking
if any of the witnesses want to make public statements about
any of the things they've said with you, are they cool for that?
Do you think any lawyer would give a blanket yes on that? No
shot. 0%
chance. Because remember, attorney client privilege, and I imagine
that extends to witnesses because your attorney is an extension
of yourself. Um, attorney client privilege is one of the things
that I don't get access to. I I don't know what you tell your
attorney. So the the idea that she would get a blanket authorization
from her attorney for people to leak what they conferred about
or what they spoke about. That's I don't believe that. That's
crazy. Does he think Wait, wait, wait. Does he think Pixie's
lawyers like consulted with me for like strategy or
something? Is that what he thinks? He thinks the the legal experts
came to me and were like, "Hey, we we actually don't know what
to do. Mr. Streamer streamer man, could you could you give us
like a little bit of strategy on this? Could you tell us like
what's going on? We don't really know.
no. They took a statement for me. They took They took a statement
from me. What does he think that they Why Why wouldn't I? And
by the way, I don't think I would have said anything in that
statement that I wouldn't have said on my public stream. I don't
remember exactly what I said, but I'm pretty confident I didn't
say anything in that statement, whatever we were talking about,
that I haven't already said on
stream. What's up, big Aaron? How's it going? Welcome.
Welcome. Oh,
wait. Wait. Could that be it? Oh, hold on. I don't know. Wait.
Oh, wait. Hold on. Oh, god. Wait. The conspiracy brain.
Do you mind if I say I sat down with your attorneys? And she
says, "Yeah, sure. What day? What for?" Exactly. Did she misread
this as him saying, "Do you mind if I sit down with your attorneys?"
And she was asking, "Sh Oh, that would explain the instant response
Oh, wait. So, do you think this means he was She could have interpreted
as him asking for a second
meeting. Oh. Oh. I just wanted to say it
Oh, I almost don't even want to make fun of how he is because
I I like that he's just going in the totally like wrong. It's
very funny to me that he's like totally making things up. I almost
don't want to mock him on stream. I almost don't want to like
be like, "No, no, no, no. It's probably more boring and like
oriented towards reality. I just want to see where he'll go to.
Where how far will he run in the wrong
direction means he didn't sit down with them, but he wants to
lie that they don't streng. That's that's what it looks like.
Now, maybe he met with him one time and he wanted to and she
thought he was asking to meet with him a
time. Well, actually, wait, that's easy to figure out. You should
subpoena his logs. I already requested that in Discovery, I believe.
I doubt they'll produce it for me since they don't seem to be
giving anything else.
But I think that's one of the reasons why he was spooked. Not
because of any public threat I've made, but because he would
have to actually provide proof for the things that he's been
doing. And I imagine what he's probably doing is running. Uh
if Destiny wants like access to any of that stuff by the way,
uh I think I could just say like
um as long as the identities are protected, I would I will make
a statement and then I think that would let him subpoena me,
right? I will say I explain No, no, no. I'm not going to say
that. Oh, yeah. I know. No. I'm going to save that one. Deleting
all of his evidence and actually deleting all of his logs and
actually trying to hide as much as he can. Nope. But he thinks
because he's in Canada that he's safe from it all.
Uh yeah, I think I just would be I don't know. I haven't been
served. I I would be. Yeah, but I haven't deleted anything. It's
like all We're just We're just chilling, man. It's my guess.
That's why he doesn't want to. Just don't oppose this. Just let
this gag order go or let the uh this stuff being filed under
what is it? Protect like the protective order go through. Just
don't oppose the protective order and then you'd gain the right
to subpoena me. I think I think that's how it works, right?
Be officially in this
case. Exhibit B. Hold on. Let me let me pull up exhibit B here.
Bro, this is the um great link. This is the this is the clip
I got sent and I just like I was like almost crying laughing.
Clearly heroic individual's identity. Um so let me see. Let me
just see. Oh wow. Uh I don't know who this could possibly You
what? I'm glad that they protected this person's identity. They
could really be in a lot of trouble. This person's apparently
been threatened. Whoever this person is could have been in a
lot of trouble if their identity was exposed. Now, now it's funny
that he's laughing.
Remember, for initially, I was basically a serial. Okay. Then
when the case was filed, well, nobody nobody ever said that.
We're always very clear. It's not serial rap.
Habitual consent violator is kind of what we like to go. Single
law firm, let alone multiple law firms uh that I had retained
for this. And then it was when it took me too long to respond.
It was because I was representing myself because I was so arrogant
that I thought I was a master lawyer. And then when my
You do think you're a master lawyer. You literally in multiple
times in this thing have said like, "No, obviously I know way
better than her lawyers." Legal team finally responded. They
were inept and they were bad at their job because they waited
to run the clock down to respond and apparently was a bad lawyer.
Nobody has ever called Andy B a bad lawyer. Literally nobody
has ever said that. I he is hallucinating like commentary that
happened. Show me anybody who has said the things that Desi is
saying happened. And then when her legal team showed up, they
were big shots. Hot shots is what was said cuz they done so many
different types of law on all by
who? Dude, who ever said Pixie's lawyers were hot
shots? He's just he's just like blatantly lying. He is literally
just rewriting reality. And again, um, for anybody who like knows
what's going on, anybody who's like looked into this at all,
it's just embarrassing, right? It's just for the clapping seals
is again he is he is like what you need to understand about this
audience in this stream when he does it is he is like a magician.
Okay. And what do we remember the uh is it the illusionist? No,
no, no, no, no. the prestige. I think I think it's the prestige
where they say the thing you need to understand about the audience
when they sit down is they want to be fooled, right? Everybody
in that audience wants to be
fooled. And so he can give as long as he goes makes a puff of
smoke appear somewhere else and he gives some thing that isn't
even a that's just not not it's not real at all. It's just an
illusion, right? as long as he can give them that, they'll look
over at it and even if he's really badly stuffing a pigeon into
his pants, okay, they'll keep looking over at the puff of smoke
because they they want to be tricked. They want to believe that
magic is real. They want to believe that Destiny didn't do these
things. And they will take any justification for that that they
can get anything. Anything. They're they're grasping for anything.
It doesn't have to be real or tangible. Daddy, please give me
any story that makes the bad things go away. Rico was coming.
It was going to be a big deal, right? And then my case was hopeless
and I was getting buried. The lawyer from Puerto Rico is coming.
You better be scared. Blah blah blah. And then it started to
change to, okay, he has highpowered lawyers. They've defended
master across the globe. That was the first thing we said when
we found out who your lawyers were. I don't know where any of
the other stuff's coming from. I tweeted about Andy B being your
lawyer the second he signed on Prohawk Viche. Unfortunately,
her lawyers are getting bad faith attacked and now everybody's
getting intimidated. Look at the changing. And
now this fat uh loser Yep. Oh, I guess he's not part of the case.
So, can we say more about him? This fat loser, right, is a Oh,
isn't it funny how inept her legal team? And by the way, I'm
just giving you because I do pre-watch the feature. Okay, just
so you know, the spin that people are going to try to do. I'm
going to go through this. This is going to be a seven hour video
on my YouTube. Okay, I'm going to go through this case from start
to finish cuz holy [__] All right, but the spin by
all the end of this is going to be Destiny only won this case
on a technicality because he had highowered lawyers and he buried
this poor girl um under a mountain of
No, the the spin would be that they wouldn't have been able to
find evidence of you sending it after the fact. That might be
that you didn't send it after Cardi, but like morally you literally
signed an affidavit. By the
way, give me what? Another month and this guy wants to race.
We can race. I'll race
him. Wait, wait, wait. Hold on. I need to get some donations
or something out of this. I don't know if I want to show my face
somewhere. I could like record it. Yeah, that's what I'd do.
I get like a GoPro and record it. I'll go for a run.
Vexacious motion or litigation. That's going to be the
He's right. There's going to be so much hope if Destiny comes
out on top of this case.
No, I I've literally said already that like they might not be
able to find it. He already signed the affidavit. Where's the
cope? Hold on. The cope is that he didn't sign an affidavit admitting
to the behavior directly. He sent that non-consensually. That's
not even like that's just factually admitted to the case. That's
not that's not an element of contention that he sent non-consensually
is not an element of contention. This is just about how much
Pixie should get in compensation for it. Where do you think Where
do you think like any of the moral condemnation you should have
should come from? Is it based on how much money one of them gets?
Are
you very embarrassing for some of these people? I I feel like
they might not even know that Destiny signed a statement saying
that. Like they might actually be too dumb. The fire child person,
the who is it? Noxen.
All of these people are like just too minded to actually go and
just read any document themselves without the Destiny
Crazy. What what people will try to sell as the um ending narrative
for all of
anyway. The name is redacted. Yes, the name is redacted. The
avatar is not
And again, like it's funny just because of the context of all
of this and because I can bear it psychologically and financially.
Um,
but like it's funny because you're a terrible person. That's
why it's funny. It's it's just funny. It's all funny. Also, like
Yeah, it's just funny. These are It's double funny now. It's
It truly is disgusting, right? Because again, this is a federal
case. These are serious claims.
A federal judge is going to have to sit here and read. We do
a magistrate
tomorrow. Okay. The resources of the state. Listen, lawyers get
paid. They don't give a Okay. My legal team, I'm sure they're
happy. They get their money. I don't know about J. Yeah. And
he's Andy's getting a Lambo out of this. Legal team. I'm sure
it's a good family favor. They're cashing it on. Um but like
it's just a waste of like the state's time of the federal government's
time. So he's very concerned about the state. Listen guys, it's
actually not that bad for me. I can bear it. But the state is
strapped for resources. And the the state, it's all about the
state. We're so it's soed up that the state is losing its resources.
There's like a judge and a court and they're they're wasting
all of their time. I can I can afford it. I can totally afford
it. Pay no attention. Okay? Please pay no attention to the fact
that I'm trying to totally scam my audience with a $400 knife
right now. All I'm saying is I might pay 400 bucks if this comes
from an autograph from Andrew Breler. If you can get me an autographed
knife, an autographed signed certificate of authenticity. Andrew
Andrew Breler. I'm buying a Lambo based on Destiny selling these
knives because he needs some liquid cash now. Let's go.
By the way, he fought over extending 10 pages, which he knew
would get approved. He also spent five, what was it? Five different
documents trying to argue that Pixie shouldn't be able to get
a the Kiwi Farms video taken down. Yeah. Yeah. Very cool. You
love to see it. Waste. And it's just like a joke to all of these
people.
Now, it was going to be like, let's be real. It was going to
be obvious who it was just from the um like it literally No,
it doesn't have to be obvious. That's a lie. I can't watch his
watching him and other people talk about this like the people
that it doesn't have to No, it doesn't have to be obvious. No,
it's not obvious. Uh meanwhile, we go back. Well, how far do
we have to go back? Right here. Was this the Was this the time
stamp I had? Oh, somewhere around here. Wasn't it right here
where he was talking about just how obvious it was? So, he goes,
"No, no, it's not obvious. It's not obvious. Further information
after defendant publicly called for his death on the defendant.
It's not obvious. Why would you? Okay, so it's either So it's
it's one of two
people. Attached to his exhibit B is a true and correct copy
of his communication to me expressing his fear defendant. Let's
see if we can figure out who this one
is. It's not obvious. It's not obvious. It doesn't have to be
obvious. He's probably going to try to argue that all of it should
be filed under a seal or something. But realistically, I don't
need my online pseudonym protected. I'm I'm Dude, I'm already
public enemy number one, he was reading two seconds into this
document. Even when things weren't referring to me, his entire
chat was saying my name, talking about what a piece of I am.
I don't need protection for my online pseudonym. That's not what
need. That hate me are so brainbroken in their analysis. It's
so funny listening to the crazy legal theories that they spin
to try to make it so they're like, "Actually, this filing Oh,
wait, hold on. He'll have an example for us, right? He'll have
an example of where like some crazy legal theory was spun that
makes absolutely no sense that makes him like 100% guilty. Surely
I've done this somewhere, right? Or is he just going to actually
like make that up? Never reference a clip, never reference anything
real. He's going to totally make it up about me, right? I thought
we didn't we I thought I thought he went through a whole arc
with these people where he was trying to teach them how that
was a really bad thing to do. You should have an example, right?
You shouldn't just get to without looking at any clip, without
looking at any example say this person does a thing. No, it doesn't
have to be obvious. That's a lie. Their analysis is so funny
listening to the crazy legal theories that they spin to try to
make it so they're like, "Actually, this filing is really good.
This filing actually is is hold on. I can give a crazy legal
theory. I can do it." Uh, I thought for a little bit that that
um distributor or whatever the the the adjective that's used
in
USC 6 USC
6851 whatever this was uh disclose I thought disclose possibly
possibly might have meant uh so publish that publish could have
meant like maybe old links right I think there are people who
have made that argument I think under some circumstances that
argument could actually work. But now I believe that that argument
probably or make accessible that that might not be the case that
you might not be able to argue that to get to stay within Cardi.
But hey, that's that's look I can do it and he can at
all really good for them. You got but I don't even know if that
I don't even know if that was um I don't even know if I like
knew that. I just I think I I read a couple cases where basically
they talked about how links worked and stuff and I was like,
"Oh, if they view it this way and this is like um the way they've
they've decided these cases, then that might not hold up. Watch
like the next minute." It's everything these people say is so
stupid. Like the the quotes like referenced earlier on.
Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. But I'm sorry. It's like it's just
very very
very they're like not saying the name, they're protecting the
name. I click on this my but like realistically like you realize
they've done this to like five other people in this case, right?
I could maybe understand maybe
but like I think those people consented to their screen names
being used like I I think those screen names were like introduced
previously, right? So they did it to Abby. I think the ABMC screen
name the ABMC screen name was used. It was in the defendants
disclosures,
right? Pixie disclosures. I don't know if you say defendants
disclosures there, but like that name was used already.
So five. Did they do that to like bunch of other people? I could
understand it happening once, but if you're making mistake after
mistake, I'm sorry. You should recuse yourself or or ask the
tell the plaintiff. He's very concerned for all of these people
actually. He's just incredibly concerned. You're not suitable
for representing them in a case of this caliber or or in any
federal case at all. stick to I don't know what law they do in
Puerto Rico or whatever local jurisdiction you're that's like
where that's like where all of the the Browns live, right? All
the disgusting trash browns in Puerto Rico. Whatever kind of
disgusting trash brown person law they do in Puerto Rico, disgusting
Puerto Ricans under immigration sounded like the what she specialized.
Just do do that. Stick to that. I there's no reason to suspect
or like I don't need um I've said that to Pixie, but I I told
Pixie I was like I literally said, "Hey, I'm going to talk about
that on stream." And then I said it live like publicly, right?
So realistically, I want my my identity protected, but I don't
need like um the the pseudonym protected is whatever,
Yeah. Like what he's saying here, and again, I know these guys
live in a separate world. This is child's play. This is not how
the real world works,
Why do protective orders exist?
I like I wish, bro, I thought
every time I hear this guy say something, I'm just like more
embarrassed that I ever thought he had anything poignant to say
at all.
Why do protective orders exist? Men don't show up to court in
a guy fox mask saying, "Your honor, it's okay that they know
my video game name, but I would like to protect my real life
name." No. In real life, in the big boy world, if you want to
go to court, then you your name is on the line. That's it. It
has to be. Your your reputation is on the line. Your testimony.
Wait, but the court would know the name. I can't not show the
name to the court. The credibility of you as a person is on the
line because now you're in the big boy world. Okay. This isn't
a real You're not making a real argument. The court knows. There
is no legal downside for you in my name being protected in public
filings. Why is he pretending that that is the case? Sorry. I
Every time I ask why, it's because he is not making a real argument.
He is pretending to be right. He's pretending to be so the clapping
seals can go. Sorry. Yeah. The the clapping seals will go. Yeah.
Yeah. There's no reason for him to protect it. Objective orders
need justification to prove a reason for it. Uh this man has
a massive platform and he's called for my death. He actually
admits to calling for my death earlier in this stream.
Yeah, that's the justification. It's literally in the document.
He's read it now. I've read it multiple times. Patty XD, are
you confused? Are you lost? Do you have a where your brain matter
where your gray matter should be? Is that what's going on right
now? Are you okay? Do we need a neurosurgeon for you to remove
that directly from your matter? Plaintiff initially filed this
case after demanding $15 million for me. All right. You don't
get to make those types of supporting claims behind a fat video
game avatar. Either stand tall. Hey, and that's just the cheeks.
The avatar is very good-looking. Actually, the avatar is just
the cheeks. Okay. The court aren't aware of these
allegations. Oh, that person is totally disingenuous. That person
should just go, right? That person's like actually just a brain
dead. Totally brain dead.
Christ. It's literally in the document. It's in this document
that he's
reading. What are we doing? What are we What are we doing on
what you're saying? Him calling your avatar fat is so telling
that Kelly won. Kelly did win. Kelly totally owned this guy again
is funny. Dude, Kelly owns this guy. He's like, just call Why
Why don't you go after Kelly, bro? This is Listen, why am I the
target? Why am I the target for everybody? Okay, Nicholas Dorio,
go after Queen and Destiny, go after Kelly Jean. Okay, I didn't
call you fat. Stay away from my calling me fat. [__]
Uh, you what are you doing? Go after Kelly. She's the one talking
[__] about your looks. I even I even say look, I
don't want to call another guy fat. Okay, I got a I got a bit
of a gut going. Okay, I don't I'm not going to call another dude
fat. That Well, unless it's Nick, but that's just cuz Nick is
very jolly
looking anyway. Sorry. Or do a big boy protective order and super
save all your or whatever. This half in half out is what is a
big boy protective order and super save all your what is that
is are we doing a little boy protective
What? Wait, is there What's a big boy protective order and super
save all
your
what? I Is this not a big boy protective order? Is this not a
Is this Is this not a big boy protective order? I'm so confused.
Stand tall on what you're saying.
Or do a big boy protective order and super save all your or whatever.
This half in half out
is I think he means don't use screen names. Yeah, the protective
order. Hold on. Just to be clear, I'll put my name in if there's
a protective order, right? You can't give an affidavit with your
screen name.
You can't do that. You have to have your legal name on an affidavit.
Yeah, I have no issue disclosing my identity at all as long as
I know it's
protected. That's literally Does he think Does anybody think
that I'm not going to disclose my identity? I've said that on
stream multiple times. As long as they can prove to me that they
can uh withhold withhold my identity from the public and make
it not okay for him to say it, then I'll I'm in. I'm
good. What? Who's confused on that? That's literally what this
protective order is setting up. Well, for other people, too.
But you said public things about him and
he can say whatever is public.
Okay. Well, oh my god, the cognitive victims in here. Jesus.
I should I have to stop reading these chats. You guys are I mean
you guys like get off on being This is like you've you've like
actually absorbed Destiny's public humiliation fetish and you
guys try to go in and act it in other chats by acting It's very
disgusting. Please don't include me in your kink. It's very gross.
Please off. Stay plugged up somewhere else. Back to the cave.
Get out of here. Let her know. I was like, "Hey, just so you
know, that should have definitely been censored. That would have
been insane not to censor it. If it wasn't somebody who had spoken
publicly,
right?" So, yeah, that like if I had spoken publicly on it, this
is me asking to um speak publicly on it, right? I'm just going
to say like, "Oh, I'm going to say that on stream." Oh, boy.
Can witnesses not remain anonymous? Obviously, the filers reveal
themselves, but I feel the witnesses should show up some protection
if it was more. No, there's exceptional circumstances where they
can be anonymous, like in child crime cases.
Maybe Oh. What?
What? This guy's got a massive platform. He's talking about killing
me. He's telling people that they should kill me. That's I feel
like that's a pretty exceptional case, maybe. But no, you have
a right to because imagine if if like 10 people came out to support
a Pixie, but they were all anonymous. How am I supposed to defend
myself against claims? Um, how am I supposed to defend myself
against claims if I don't know who's making any any accusations
against me? You can't do that. No, he would know. He would know.
You're just not allowed to disclose it. You would know. He's
not that stupid. He's not actually that
Hey, Electus, thank you for the new sub. Let's go. Three months.
Thank you very much. Thank you. Thank
you. There just I just don't want it disclosed publicly and I
want him to be under penalty if he discloses it publicly. Right?
That's what I
want. Pro tip, make sure to call the magistrate a magistrate
judge. In my state, we have at least one magistrate who specifically
said at a silly she wants to be called a magistrate judge. I'll
probably say your honor for everything. I'll ask my
um all the guidance on that. But I sorry, I I had a a little
Well, they should have to reveal themselves to you, but just
not to the public. Oh, sure. cinema. You can do that easily.
That's called filing under seal. But the problem is plaintiff
plaintiff's council
that I don't know. I I don't know where they practiced law at
or what they do or if they're even real lawyers. I know that
they're super ass about me criticizing their inability to understand
the English language or basic rules of federal civil procedure.
I know that that makes them very assigned, but this is unacceptable
behavior. Like you should be cringing. Oh, sure. Sure. I meant
like he'll have the ability to subpoena me through his lawyers.
Yeah. Oh, I I actually thought it was just Listen, if I if I
if stuff for me could be filed under seal, I'd be fine with that.
Right now, that some music school dropout online is is reading
through your court filings and can see that you are clearly incapable
and doing a disservice to both the federal court. Why is he so
racist? I don't know why he keeps pointing out that this judge
is from Puerto Rico is very weird. Puerto Rico. What? Puerto
Ricans are Americans, right? Aren't Puerto Ricans Americans and
to the client that you're supposedly representing? You're not
qualified for the case. You're in way the over your head and
no amount. I just want to point out in case anybody was curious
if
um just, you know, a fun little fun little thing. Fun fact. Fun
fact, fun fact.
Okay. He um he said earlier, "Oh, I can't even watch this guy.
It's so disgusting. It's so disgusting. I can't even watch this
guy. What's this? What's this? I'm up there. I'm up there with
one of the all-time greats. I bumped Vos out. Vos, you are number
three. I am number two. I am almost comparing to Hassan. Now,
I understand Hassan holds a special place in his heart. Okay,
I understand Hassan holds a special place, but I am number two
now. All right, maybe one day we'll get there.
Good times. Good times. Oh, wrong one. I think this one. This
one. Yes. No amount of lawyers at your firm flying to Texas for
cancer or pneumonia sicknesses that you're having is an excuse
for like the disgusting negligence that you've shown or ineptitude
that you've shown handling this case in my opinion. But you know,
who the [__] am I? I guess except the defendant.
I guess in a way what I really You know what? What I really mean
to say, let me be more concise. What I really mean to say is
thank you plaintiff's counsel. Thank you. That's what I mean
to say. Truly, thank you. Truly, thank you. Thank you. Thank
you.
Make sure that next time you file the request for a page extension
so you can have 20 pages to write about how mad you are about
the mean things I say about you. I hope they do file for page
extensions to go just to 11 pages so that Destiny gets ass again
and tells Andy B to go write up a uh opposing motion. Okay, Andy,
go write up an opposing motion. I know it's going to cost me
another 10 grand, but Andy, you're worth it. Do not let them
file with extra Oh, they're filing with extra pages anyway. Well,
you know what? It I'm going to sell another $400 knife to my
fans and it'll be
okay. I'm sorry. This is just so funny
me. Where is it?
He refers to me as a disgusting and repeatedly accuses me of
grabbing random people to perjure themselves. Defendant accuses
plaintiffs council me of bad faith arguments explicitly lying
and abuse of the court system. He's been Hold on. See, he's going
to touch on it now, right? He won't just he won't go past granding
grabbing random people to perjure themselves, right? He won't
just um he won't just skip that one again. telling his followers
that we have no understanding of the federal rules of civil procedure
because uh we allegedly did not adhere to proper procedures by
filing redacted declarations of the witness and then the stuff
about Lauren opposed on Kiwi Farms the defendant attack Lauren
Hayden a friend a potential witness okay I do like I do like
you know that's a fair point about Kiwi Farms they'll definitely
the judge will go wait hold on you get this from Kiwi Farms no
that is a great defense this evidence is on Kiwi farms. Oh, we
have to we have to strike that from the recorded as an individual
likely to come to information lies about and talk about how he
would like to get her dispar because she doesn't support the
plaintiff. Yes, we've read this. We've read this court and then
he did and he made you go. Yep. The and the mag.
We're back to going to this this whole thing.
lol is expressed fear for providing any further information after
publicly called his death on the YouTube channel. Keep in mind
again how disgusting this is, right? This guy has streamed for
months. This guy has streamed for months covering all this, but
he won't stand up and testify
for for a plaintiff. Just want So it's only to make money. Actually,
I think this is actually right now that I think about it. I do
want to protect it from Destiny. I don't trust that he wouldn't
try to leak it. He's actually expressed publicly, don't you know?
He said as soon as he gets my information, he would leak it immediately.
And then he got someone else's information, leak that immediately.
Okay. I actually do think a protective order is appropriate.
I trust Andy B way more than Destiny. Okay. Andy B would never
leak my name. This Destiny guy, he's a shady character.
He's a shady character just to make money off of this because
he's farming this the same way you farmed anybody else involved
with
this. Couldn't possibly be that I find you disgusting, your behavior
disgusting. The fact that I once supported you disgusting and
that makes this content both interesting to me and like uh I
don't know, just it's just interesting to me. Yeah, I like covering
this stuff. I like knowing it. I don't like you. You're a bad
person. You're somebody I thought was a good person. like a super
helpful person to like society. I was mind read and now I'm like,
"Oh, I should make other people understand that you're like a
horrible person." Be good.
What's up, Tan? The three other potential witnesses also believe
the defendants committed crimes against them by disclosing intimate
images of them without their consent, but they were afraid of
pursuing legal action because of how he has publicly harassed
and assaulted me and anyone who has supported me, including my
council. They were like, "You have to include this. He attacked
us too, remember?
I mean, you're reporting the news. Should journalists have to
testify in a trial they're covering? Yeah, exactly. It's just
coverage. It's just coverage.
Okay. That's all it is. Three of these witnesses have expressed
to me fear that their physical well-being could even be put at
risk if they attempt to pursue justice. Oh my god.
Patch here to exhibit C is a trunk copy of my conversation with
one of those witnesses whose screen name is length
Let's see. We already looked at all these, right?
This one. Hold on. I think I saw a clip of this one, too. This
a Twitter message. Steven Bonell has abused his position of power
and community to gain favor and harass people in the past. I
find his actions and terrifying. I will never feel comfortable
being a witness in this case against Steven unless my identity
is protected. I fear for my family, friends, and my current and
future careers. without protection. I am almost certain I will
receive harassment and doxing from his
community. Is this a single DM with no?
This is a single DM, right? Because unless they white boxed all
their responses here. It looks like they got one message from
this person.
Huh? Oh, a text or a text. I'm sorry, not a
DM. I also like Yeah, I like how there's no date on it.
Wait, what is
Monday, Friday, on the 30th. When did we file our Was it on the
30th? On the 30th. Do you think she asked? I I bet this is fake.
That's pretty weird. Uh I wouldn't be shocked if they talked
on one platform and then said, "Could you text us through like
another platform if you don't want uh any of this stuff exposed
or something?" I don't know why it's just the one text. Yeah,
I have no idea. I bet this is a fake message. I don't believe
this. It reads like a and and and clearly opposing council and
plaintiff are dumb enough to fake something in the stupidest
way
possible. I just Yeah, I look at this and I'm like, yeah, I'm
guessing that that's like sent through some other platform, people
not wanting to give away their identity or something. I have
no idea. Um I haven't seen anything fake so far. I don't know
why he's like ex I don't know why he just immediately goes to
the most conspiratorial explanation.
Nice typed out message with proper capital. Yeah. Is this one?
Yeah. I have I have no record of any of these people. They didn't
forward us any like unredacted filings at all. They didn't send
us any information about any of these people. There's literally
nothing.
I don't know if that would be true.
Destiny is just suggesting they're committing perjury. Yeah.
Well, he's done it multiple times, right? That is again him saying
they're faking evidence right now.
Again, by the way, these lawyers who apparently are total feel
like when Destiny does uh defame them and say that they're like
perjuring themselves publicly on his platform with like millions
of people who could potentially see it across Twitter or like
they they clip his channel, it gets put up everywhere, right?
There there are like millions of people who view Destiny's
And he does these things and he goes, "Yeah, no, no. It couldn't
possibly hurt
reputation." Brother, you're like, you are just totally you're
in conspiracy mode making things up about these people with no
evidence. Of course, it could
them. Yeah. Like, who says Steven Bonell? Seriously, somebody's
saying that it's like an affidavit, but if you want to have them
fill out an affidavit or to fill one out and sign it, then have
them do that. fill out an affidavit and sign it. Not an affidavit.
This is a stage. This is a stage text,
Also, you're filing a redacted. Why are you filing redacted screen
names? If you're filing a redacted version, why are you not even
putting their name whose screen name
is? Almost every individual I communicated with expressed not
only their disgust for defendants's actions, but also their reluctance
to speak up publicly due to their concern and fear your defendant
retaliating against them. Why didn't you get all of these statements
then prior to filing the
complaint? Is that something you have to do? I just don't think
that's a
requirement sign today. Nice.
Why are there no previous texts in the Yeah, there's statements
during discovery. No. Well, you can I think like you should get
you should get your in the row like in in a row early in the
case. Like they probably would have been asking these people
for statements. I would imagine if these people were in January
saying I am too scared to like have my name on the record. This
guy scares me. Then there was probably some further discussion
that happened like hey I know you're like afraid but we can protect
you. You should give us a statement. And then eventually some
of those people would have gone away, right? like this is obviously
the natural like progression of events, but he's pretending that
that's like unthinkable. Doesn't want to put the actual natural
progression of events into his audience's head because then they
would have, you know, some tools to actually accurately evaluate
the
case. Yes, Latigious. Yeah, latigious gamer. Exactly. Aren't
they explaining why they didn't get the statements in this very
motion that he is currently reading? Yes,
exactly. in that screenshot. Like I said, I think that
um the Destiny Vars database, isn't it super popular to file
this motion the day before the hearing, too? Means your lawyers
don't have a chance to drop it. Yeah, I it was intentional, too,
because I think normally um I don't know if these motions actually
affect the hearing. I think these motions, so if I'm not mistaken,
I think these motions and the I I'll check right now, but my
recollection was that these motions and the things that went
with them, these motions and like the the other documents that
went with them were actually not filed as a part of the preliminary
injunction hearing. So, we'll see. Text of the proposed order,
text of the proposed order, text of the proposed order. We'll
see. So, this one's Jacqueline Beera.
This one is Jacqueline
Becca and this one is Jacqueline Becker. So these are all in
the US District Court. These are not I don't believe these orders
would be a part
of support of
492. Hold on.
Uh, some of them might be. No, some of them might be going into
that
case. It's
possible it's filing under
seal. There might be something with regards to Abby that needs
to be filed under seal, which is the uh actually the text message
that we are hoping we get him get a chance to see him read.
I Let me get a drink.
Oh, sorry. I went I went to the wrong time stamp. This was meant
to just show when he's like when he's whining there. My bad.
Normally, um, it takes What are you saying? There's no way to
know. There's no way to possibly know. And then he's like, "Oh,
this is obviously like Queen or JC responses." And they had until
the sixth, but they made sure to get this one in tonight. They
got this one in on
Problem. So, they just got it in on time. He's complaining that
they got it in on time. Okay.
Why does any of this
anything under seal
Plaintiff requests that the seal remain in place for the duration
of litigation, including any appeals to ensure ongoing protection
of the witnesses. This duration is consistent with the need to
prevent further emotional psychological harm plaintiff and the
individuals referenced in her declaration as supported by do
Williams v. Williams. What do you think this case looked like?
I don't know.
No way. We're buying pacer documents for another case.
Cool. He's
got this person. This person's home or pliff has some recollection
of the events. They became aware of some encounter. Could not
recall everything that happened. Pliff had never been with a
female before and had any interest in being with a female. No
other thing. Jesus Christ. Noticing a phone in Williams hand
that night. PL asked Williams following morning she wanted to
place Williams probably she did indeed record sex between the
two of them told her to delete the video. Williams falsely told
plaintiff she had nothing to worry about as her face was not
on the video. The reassurance meant little as Williams said she
was not going to delete the video but instead would keep it in
the vault. Pliff again told Williams. The plaintiff would feel
better if it was deleted than the video. She refused to do so.
Discover Williams not to delete the video in or about May 3rd
2023. At the time, Williams casually mentioned the wife and um
of her
Brad and listened in a state of shock as she realized video of
the nonential acts being passed around. The Mississippi Highway
Patrol were both at the time. Otherwise, this what happened.
Are we getting to a point
or you believe Pixie's Puerto Rican lawyer filed on time? The
audacity is
just dismissed.
Are we done with everything for my These motions probably could
be referred to the magistrate judge. Magistrates handle a lot
of pre-trial stuff. Oh, maybe
motion for leave if I redacted evidence in support of the Oh,
we have evidence from this anonymous person. Oh, boy. We do.
Okay, this is the witness.
I really want to find it cuz he has said previously that this
is totally made up and there is no evidence of this. So, I do
want to see his reaction to this. This is like one of most Yeah,
I'm going be honest. I didn't expect this to turn into open anti-
Puerto Rican racism.
well, punctuality is a construction for him by whiteness.
Ah, he is becoming conservative before our very eyes. He's becoming
red pill and conservative. Listen, Walter. Walter, you better
lock your down with a Fresh and Fit podcast. Walter, okay? Because
it's about to be Myron and Stephen. Myin and Esteban. All right.
No more Walter. Walter's going to be out. Myin and Estabbon running
the Fresh and Fit podcast cutting these down to size. Keeping
the whole case alive. This is the big one,
boys. Okay. Correctly moves this court for leave to submit evidence
in redacted form and believe to file under seal the unreacted
evidence in support of the declaration of this person who was
filed on May 2nd 2025. Plaintiff files this announced evidence
support
decoration. Hold on what why isn't he reading? There's no way
this is just quiet. Why does he just read? In the instant case,
good cause is unclear as the exhibit contains highly sensitive
details of private sexually acts implicating the substantial
rights of the declar and other individuals. Public disclosure
of their identities will expose the dementilation help
violations. By the way, sex tapes all the time. He thinks I don't
know the girls in them, but videos of him [__] Oh,
thank okay. We censored her name. This doesn't even exist. and
Pixie like Lympho. He just sent me another one over
there. Why not post the the this person says we don't know who
this is. Okay, even though they accidentally
Okay, so I just want I want to point out for all the totally
in here because I know you guys watch you can't get enough. Okay,
I love you. I love you. You'll figure it out eventually. This
person apparently in November of 2023 before ever possibly knowing
that these videos could exist describes videos that would later
videos and audio that would later be leaked, okay, to that would
later be leaked onto the internet would cause a massive scandal.
They do it a full year before those videos were leaked to the
internet.
They somehow tapped into the schizosphere and made up the fact
that Destiny had these videos and would send them to people a
full year before we actually knew in the public in any way that
those videos have been
leaked. Um and and Destiny saying this is just a lot. There's
no way that this this just didn't happen. This just didn't apparently
she's um she's just psychic. Apparently she's a psychic and this
is not Rose. No, this is in support of the declaration of
AbbyMC. She's playing the long con and I do remember and he only
said he only sent it to Rose, right? Yeah. Well, that's what
he
said. They back to the future did. Okay, dude. I I just I just
want to know how he's going to explain to these people that this
happened. This person says Pepe laugh in 2023. Do they know Do
they know why it's funny that is in 2023?
Name of the file. They put her first name in the file name.
Bro, where's the message of me sending her the thing? This is
I didn't know this would be hearsay. I didn't know what the this
is. Wait, no, no, no. This is uh this is evidence in support
of her saying that this this happened. By the way, I will say
if you remember back to like rap reviews when Destiny did rap
reviews when it came down to like a he said she said, let's say
in this case, okay, for example, in this case, people say um
she's saying you sent me the videos. Oh, that's like that that's
hearsay because she says you also deleted the logs or the links
to to you sending the videos, right? Okay. Well, what's Destiny's
number one thing when it's a when it's a review? Okay, he's doing
a review and he decides, okay, it's a he said, she said. I need
some evidence. You know what I would expect? Messages to friends
is always the first one. Did she message the friends and say
what happened? Are is there is there some record of her believing
that it was like an assault on the night of? Here's the here's
the exact circumstantial evidence that he always brings up. Hey,
when this happened, right? When this happened. It's contemporary
is a good good word for it. Contemporaneous logs. Yes. Contemporaneous
evidence. We have timespecific evidence that shows that this
happened, right? That they're not making it up. They're not just,
you know, changing their mind after the fact. Contemporaneous
evidence that shows that this this happened. And he's going,
"Wait, wait, wait. They don't have the logs of me." That's actually
what she said in her declaration that she didn't have logs of
you sending the video because you deleted them. That's entire.
That's exactly what she said. And she said, "I have vlogs of
me telling a friend that he had sent these videos and I
names." By the way, I I will say, by the
I No. Nope. I'm not saying anything else. This
is This is obviously exactly what she said she had. This is obviously
exactly what she said she had. This the whole point of this is
that Destiny is saying there's no proof of the Cardi thing. This
now gives
evidence that they should look for these things in discovery
that yeah, some of this stuff should be subpoenaed. Hey, we should
actually look
it. Why wouldn't that person who says that he send the link just
send the Discord log that has the link to the video? Because
he deleted all of their
logs. Are you Yeah, you are Decisis. I see your name. Yeah, you
are a
um listen, I think you're probably about to come from the public
humiliation you're engaging in, right? You're you're in this
humiliation ritual. You're doing it to yourself. You're saying
things in the chat. So, I'll let you finish. I won't I won't
time you out. I'll just let you finish coming. You can keep
yourself. What do
we Now he's acting incredulous because he needs DJs to be incredulous,
right? This is, by the way, this is the exact exact evidence
that she said she had that I said, "Oh, if she has that contemporaneous
evidence, that is a total game changer." Total game changer,
right? And I believe he said, "This evidence couldn't possibly
exist. She's lying." I think that's I'm pretty sure that's what
he
said. Uh, even if she doesn't have the video anymore, how the
hell does he explain that she knew about this two years ago?
That's a fantastic question. Shut it down. That's a fantastic
question that anybody who's not completely cognitively would
also ask. So, congratulations on not having it in your brain.
Okay. You can sometimes line here say in support interlock applications.
What? I don't know if that has to do anything. She the this declarant
claimed that she had logs of me supposedly sending her these
things despite the fact I deleted them to hide them. No, she
never claimed that actually. She literally never Oh, he's just
he's just actually making things up now. She didn't claim that.
She didn't claim that. Can somebody grab me a time stamp? I don't
know if Ry is still around. Somebody grab me a time stamp of
him going through the Abbey Declaration. Let's just watch him
cover the Abbey Declaration because he should know from reading
that declaration because I certainly read it and wasn't a total
reading it,
right? This is what she said she had was contemporaneous logs
telling a friend about these these videos.
So why not just post
that? There's also a message missing in the middle of those two.
It's grayed out as the same color. Oh, you're right. And so that's
not redacted. That's just um that's just doctorred cuz they're
hiding stuff here. If they wanted to hide something here, they
should redact it. It should be redacted like in these black boxes,
not
doctorred. Okay.
I'm just waiting for any argument about why there would be contemporaneous
evidence of you saying of you sending these things in
2023. That's I would just love to
know. I'm sure at some point we'll figure it out, right?
literally Okay, if you're a DGR, you have to look at this silence
and be like, "What the is?" Wait, I thought we were winning,
buddy. Buddy, we were winning. I thought we were w Aren't we
doing good? I thought we were doing so good. Wait, what are you
Why are you totally silent right now?
Huh? Brother, you got to do better. You got to do better than
this. Is he good? Anything else open?
right.
Does he not want to go f Wait, would he not want to go find out
what Abby said? Or wouldn't Wouldn't he just said, "Oh, didn't
she say she had logs of me? Wouldn't you want to go open up
declaration? What's What's going on, buddy? Are you
okay?" Oh, connections. Oh god, I feel like I'm feverish. I feel
like I have a
I'm suddenly flushed. Okay, I don't want to spoil connections
for myself. He's going to play connections. I'm not
connections. That's very funny. That is very funny. Oh my goodness.
Okay, we have to go find Hold on. I I wish Where's my Where are
my linkers at? Is it just cuz we're on late that we got no linkers
ready to fight for the cause? This is up. I have to go find my
own links. Hold on. I'll do it cuz cuz why not? Last night on
Destiny. Oh. Uh, no. Not that one. That's the wrong one. That
one. Yeah.
hello. Oh, hello.
The the whoever Abby would be this with the screen name Abby
MC. Ah, yes. Oh, who did that? Spruce, thank you for the gifted
sub. Thank you. Thank you.
Hold on. She won't respond. Still trying to date her and then
he's like threatening to kill himself and then he's like trying
to send like he's like, "Okay, this is their big meme."
Okay, so one thing to keep in mind is the um Okay, I'm saying
something we've known. There are four causes of action listed
on the initial complaint. Uh you have Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait,
hold on. I don't I didn't grab the time stamp here. My bad. So
the time
here in November 2023 after the statute's effective date C exhibit
22 decoration of C. Thus the court has subject under restriction
and plaint likely to success on one merit of the party claim.
So it's an important one because this will bring the alleged
stuff entering into the statute. Is thisation public?
Okay, it's a public one. Okay, let's see. Let's see what he says.
Let's see. Let's just see how it goes. Revealing information
about themselves. I don't understand how people keep doing this.
Okay. Let's go. I'm over the age of 18 and commented to write
test oath. This is my screen name as IBMC. Some people might
know who this is. Um
when you publicly confirmed who it was, you mean like hours before
this? I have personal knowledge of the matters here and if called
to testify this matter, I could confidently testify as to the
facts contained in the affidavit. I first connected with uh overt
dummy. Thank you for the gift itself. Thank you. Thank you.
I should wait for the sound effect to come up, but thank you3
discord and other platforms on September. So, here's um and Destiny
does not necessarily dispute this. Okay, so that's important
to know. March 2023 is after Cardi comes into effect. They didn't
know each other. He had no way to send her videos or even talk
to her before March of 2023. Anything he had sent her would be
coming under the the effect of Cardi. Cardi was already passed.
Third, he went to Miami, hung out, b did stuff. I don't know
if I should say anything about that, but
Um, hold on. Somebody said, "Why would the new party affect this
lawsuit? Wouldn't she be the one to have to say you're in a new
law? Like, if I steal something?" Um, well, because she's providing
an affidavit to try to um show that uh the original claim in
this lawsuit happened within the date range. The problem is that
they're trying to sue me in federal court because they're saying
that an action that I did was illegal under a law that only came
into effect, I think, like a year or so or whatever, after the
alleged action. And the issue is that if that is the case, then
that federal cause of action wouldn't apply. And because they
cited one federal cause of action and three state causes of action,
if the federal cause of action is dismissed because the court
lacks subject matter jurisdiction because there would be no federal
claim, just three state claims, then the whole case basically
gets ejected. So the issue is is since that one doesn't fit,
and they know that it doesn't fit, uh they lied in their initial
filing on the date that that video had allegedly been they lied
about the date. I'm sure they know that they lied about the date.
Uh now they're like basically desperately scrging around trying
to define somebody else who like okay well was there video here
blah blah blah and so even though this person was never a part
of the original complaint has never been referenced before mentioned
before now like at this like at the twilight hours they have
found somebody who is saying oh well actually I received this
video all he does is the twilight hours the person might not
have messaged them right away you have no idea about the time
course of this at all he's just totally speculating on November
of 2023 or whatever
um on or about November 3rd 2023 Destiny shared a Google Drive
link to sexually a video. I Why does he burp so much now? I don't
remember him being like this before. Um, he started to imitate
Kelly Jean's mannerisms because Kelly Jean owns him. So, he started
imitating Kelly Jean's mannerisms, including burping. Denise
the plaintiff on here. I've seen her post on Instagram here.
There's also a declaration about another person about Cherry,
which is Are you going to skip over that they lied? Uh, I don't
know if they lied or that up. He's saying they lied. I don't
know if they lied or that up. They did in their initial um what
do you call it their initial complaint they had another piece
in the complaint that said we have another person who's talking
to us who has who received this video just like 3 months ago
or something or like 6 months ago right so they said there was
another person they were trying to get to make a comment but
he didn't point that out. So this was also not part of this complaint
or a part of this case at all whatsoever. I have no idea why
that's brought up here. Yeah, this shouldn't have been included.
Declarations about other Google Drive links. Um, wait, did he
just Wait, did he just skip over this instead of which is who's
also not part of hold on or
whatever. Um, about November 3rd, 2023. Destiny shared a Google
Drive link to a video. Um, I recognize the plaintiff on here.
I've seen her post on Instagram
Okay. There's also a declaration about uh another person about
Cherry, which is who's also not part of this complaint or part
of this. Oh, so he just didn't pay attention to read. He literally
said, "Oh, this has to" But that's not what happened, right?
That's sorry. He didn't read the first sentence is about at all
whatsoever. I have no idea why that's brought up here. Uh the
Cherishin thing shouldn't be referenced, but he got asked mad
about the fact that something that's outside of this case was
mentioned and he didn't read that sentence. The first thing is
on about November 3rd, 2023, I messaged a friend of mine and
told him that Destiny had sent me the above mentioned explicit
video of himself and another woman and that I recognized the
woman as the streamer Pixie. I also told my friend that Destiny
sent me another video of him and another streamer that I recognized.
Okay. I have retained in my possession a copy of the messages
to my friend. That's what it says here.
Um, decorations about other Google Drive links. Uh, I recently
reviewed my Discord account and realized that Destiny deleted
all of his direct messages to me on this the Discord platform,
including the sharing of the video of Pixie. I retained copies
of all of my messages to Destiny as well as my messages to other
people about his non-consensual sharing of explicit
Uh, Accelerati in here it says that it's audio only, black screen
audio only. Um, I recently reviewed my Discord account and realized
that I deleted all of his direct messages to me on the Discord
platform, including uh sharing many videos of Pixie. I have retained
copies of all my messages to Destiny as well as my messages other
people about his non-consensual. Yeah. Oh, so he did read this
part. So he either totally forgot again very very, you know,
very EP boy, very EP boy, right?
But you can see here, nowhere does Abby say I have evidence of
Destiny sending me the video, right? Sorry. Like um like I don't
have direct evidence of Destiny sending I didn't save those logs.
She literally says she doesn't have those logs sharing videos.
I do not want my identity publicly revealed since I have recently
discovered that he also shared videos of himself and me with
other people without my consent just like he did. So a lot of
stuff that's not I wonder when she found that out. I wonder if
that changed her view of this whole situation possibly. Huh.
that. So, just to be clear, keeps records for the court according
to him. Yeah, who knows? I don't know why those records would
be accepted as like the the actual like you can't just have a
record that's in HTML or JSON where you could just delete any
any negative messages and say that's a record. That's insane.
Uh, I do not have want to have my identity publicly revealed
since I've recently discovered that Destiny shared explicit videos
of himself and me with other people without my consent just like
he did to Pixie and these other women. And I believe she has
sent a like a demand letter um asking Destiny for a settlement
or that she'll see him in
Right. So, it's probably why he's so anxious about this in general.
Not the subject matter of the complaint that has nothing to do
with this case. So, I don't even know if I if we end up responding
to any of this because it's, you know, whatever. But, so this
is their Twilight Hours person that they brought in for this.
Ideally, there would be some kind of evidence of any of the claims
here.
Um, I there is don't know what I'll say until they rule on this
preliminary injection, but let me just say that there is absolutely
no evidence of any of this
preliminary injection. But let me just say that there's he's
literally circling the paragraph of what they I have retained
in my position a copy of the messages to my friend. He's circling
the paragraph and saying there is no evidence of this. There
is no evidence of this. There is no evidence of this. I Is he
trying to cast a spell? Is he trying to wish that that were so?
There's absolutely no evidence of any of this, but who knows?
You know, I could be lying or I could be crazy.
I probably lead to the former.
Um, so that's So this is the a declaration of a person. We don't
know who this is though. It's just Abby MC. Thankfully, they
filed a seno under protective order.
Is there any actual evidence that you shared it after that date
or is it just her saying that there is? Uh, it's just her statement.
That's it.
So, this was his major problem was that there was no contemporaneous
evidence at all. Thus, the court has subject matter jurisdiction
and plaintiff has demonstrated a likelihood of success on the
merits of her. Okay. So, he might not have been aware because
he decided he wasn't going to read the inconvenient paragraph.
Now whether or not you believe that that's because he wanted
that be that's because he just was like uncomfortable whether
no matter what you
here I'm pretty sure oh there's some other ah
oh we'll see um
yeah it I'm going to say it
no don't I'm not going to say it. Never mind. Never mind. I'll
see what I should or shouldn't
say. Okay, I'll just say
perhaps perhaps there's a
reason perhaps there's a reason why when he mouses over this
paragraph and seeing somebody's name in it, he actually doesn't
want to read anything more there and wants to move on. Very
interesting. Very interesting.
Perhaps there's a reason that
like, you know, perhaps there's a reason he was like calling
people crazy and then he shut the up about them. What do you
guys think? Why would he go from calling somebody crazy to going,
"Oh, I don't comment on them
Huh? I
h I wonder why that might be.
Just speculation. I don't know anything special. It's just
speculation. Very
interesting. I have no inside information. I'm just speculating
on patterns that seem interesting. I'm something of a noticer.
That's what they call me. Old noticing gym over here. Okay. We
noticing things sometimes.
Bro, you are Destiny's Pazookas. Nice. Well, Pazookas is a genius.
So, if that's what's happening, we love to see
Okay. Okay. I think that's that's it. We covered We got all of
it. We got all of it, guys. We got Oh, we got
Oh, listen. We're hoping that by the end of this trial, all right,
I'm going to move up. I'm going to leaprog Hassan and maybe even
leaprog a live stream fail. Okay.
I want to make it further up. We got to get higher. We have to
get higher up. All right. In his
priority. All right. That was fun, guys. I enjoyed I enjoyed
I enjoyed. Oh, I didn't see any of my redeems. Assad is bad.
My bad, guys. I didn't see that earlier. Assad is
bad. Now it's time for Darius Mercury cap. I don't know if I'm
gonna keep doing that, dude. That's just
gh. It's just so with Darius being like a really bad person.
I don't know. This just sucks, dude. It just really sucks. That's
about That's like all you can say, right? This just sucks. Just
like a dude, dude doing
things. You know how it
is, bro? Why is Twitch just offering me nothing but like streamers
to raid
the And it doesn't even show me like there's one person I would
actually raid on Twitch and they don't show up on my actual like
suggested Twitch raids. That's so odd. Anyway, it was
Okay, got that one lined up. Okay, guys. I'm out of here. Have
a good night. I'll be back tomorrow. JT talk smug emote when?
I'm not totally sure. Okay. I will send you. If you're if you're
one of the gay dudes in chat, you're going to be very tickled
at who we're rating. Okay. You're a gay dude in chat, you're
going to love it. If you're not a gay dude, if you're a straight
dude, you might not love it as much. So, have a good one, guys.
We'll see y'all later. We'll see
later. Have a good night. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye.
Good night. Good night. Bye-bye.